Õpetaja: Mm, panen Screenshare ima
Õpetaja: ja alustame siis Zoomi salvestustest.
Õpetaja: Nii, tänane Zoom. I Ee, miiting. Näiteks, Ee. Kui mina. Lähen, Teen ise lahti enda Zoom dot com.
Õpetaja: Ee. Selle kontoga, millega me tegelikult sees oleme.
Õpetaja: Siin on miitings.
Õpetaja: Jaa, aa, mul on vale ekraan, Aga kujutage ette,
Õpetaja: et ma olen. Ee, zoom dot com is
Õpetaja: ee. Oodake üks hetk. Ma pean jälle nüüd siit otsima.
Õpetaja: Mul On taustapilt läinud mustaks nagu mingil põhjusel. Üliraske on nagu üldse midagi näha. Ma pean pärast midagi olema. Nii Nüüd on küll õige koht.
Õpetaja: Ee ühesõnaga,
Õpetaja: Ee, iga kord kui mingi recording on. Üks päev on niiöelda. Miiting on alustanud. Mul on iga päev siin Ee eraldi miiting. Niiöelda miiting, Miiting, miiting, miiting. Samal ajal on recordings.
Õpetaja: Nüüd recordingsitega. On see niimoodi, et Ee, ta ennem tegelikult. Ee, ei tekita ee, niiöelda niukest õiget Linki niiöelda spetsiifilist linki. Video üks ja video. Kaks Kui mõlemad videod on ära renderdanud.
Õpetaja: Vaata, näete, see See tänane päev on.
Õpetaja: Ta näeb Käimasolev backar. See on niiöelda käesolev miiting, onju? Hetkel ei ole nagu niukest tavapärast linki, mida ma muidu kasutaks. Küll, aga ma saan ikkagi Ee, teha Nagu selle Share lingi. Ära
Õpetaja: sellisel kujul Anyone võite. Link. Ee, las ta ollagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, copy Linked, pass, kod.
Õpetaja: Mina saan juba praegu panna. Näiteks, ma panen korra chat i kõrvalt. Ma pean Chat I õige asja
Õpetaja: tegelt. Ma ei pane Seda siia. Ma ikkagi lähen õigesse kohta. Kas ma ei tea, kas teil juhuslikult sa valid? Ee, Padlet on kuskil seal või mitte, Ma tegelikult soovitan seda teha, Mäletate Tainy Url
Õpetaja: Aini Url Dot com. Kaldkriips Kvalitee tähendab niuksesse keskkonda nagu padlet Dot com. Selle võibolla võiks panna ka endal favourite alla,
Õpetaja: sest et siin on olemas Zoomi Recordingud. Näete seda siin?
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt Ee. Googeldoxis. Üks Excel.
Õpetaja: Ma võin selle otselingi panna ka Praegult muidugi Kirjutan siia ning
Õpetaja: kas te räägite? Ma panin teile siis teooriamaterjale sinna sla.
Õpetaja: Ee, paar teemat midagi. Siis saate jälle listist maha, Niiöelda
Õpetaja: aga Padat is on siis olemas kõik lingid.
Õpetaja: Ee, see Zoomi jaoks. Ee, chat I jaoks ja nii edasi. Ja Zoom Recording viib meid siis Google Dogsi.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus on kaks siit? I
Õpetaja: Ee Üks on accounts. Kus on seal teie need profiilid ja andmed? Mis iganes
Õpetaja: teine asi On siis kuhu hakkavad tulema lingid.
Õpetaja: Mina panen siia kõigepealt kuupäeva. Kuidas saab kuupäeva panna? Ee, Control Call on. Aa, Okei, See ei ole Ju Excel, onju? Ee, see on ju kuupäeva. Ee
Õpetaja: paneme. Ma jätan korra Ruumi Kakskümmend. Kuus, null, kaheksa, kaks, tuhat,
Õpetaja: kakskümmend kuus. Ma tahaks öelda. Sakslaste arv, Et see on kuupäev.
Õpetaja: Ei ole tema jaoks. Äkki panen punktid?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on kuupäev.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi saab aru tegelt.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis Ta suurendab aastanumbreid. Aga ma teen niipse triki, kui ma panen lihtsalt ilma aastahata. Kakskümmend kuus
Õpetaja: ja null. Kaheksa on põrguline.
Õpetaja: Minu arust Kuule, Come on, Ah, Voh, väga hea, Väga kole, muidugi. Aga ma korra vaatan.
Õpetaja: Ah, Kaheksa, kolm.
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: ma võin proovida üldse niimoodi? Klassikaline, Vaata, kaks Tuhat, kakskümmend, kuus, Sidekriips Kuu null, kaheksa, kakskümmend, kuus. Sellest. Saad aru äkki?
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, ma tean, kuidas ma selle saan.
Õpetaja: Mhm, väga väga Kole formaat on ju Aga formaadi saame ära muuta formaat. Formaat?
Õpetaja: Mis on formaat ja
Õpetaja: elalmenüüs.
Õpetaja: Google Top annab punktate ja nüüd tahaks nagu Täpsemat formaati.
Õpetaja: Custom number Custom Data.
Õpetaja: Uu, aa, Miks Ee,
Õpetaja: see võiks olla? On ju tara.
Õpetaja: Ma korra tegelikult vaatan korra.
Õpetaja: Jah, nüüd ta Teeb kalendri lahti. Seda ma tahtsingi. Põhimõtteliselt on ju? Täna on siis kakskümmend kuus, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, korra kustutan. Tead, ma jätan selle. Eile oli Kakskümmend viis. Eilne video on olemas ka. Siis me eile tegime Kakskümmend ühe video.
Õpetaja: Siis selle võib kaks panna.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, kuidas siis nagu töötab, et hetkel ma sain Ee, copida. Ma saan iga kord Vaata juba, enne, kui ma siit ära lähen, saan idee järgi tänase, ee, Niiöelda Recordingu videolingi ära panna. Aga see on üks väike, aga.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma lähen korra sinna lehele. Kus see on, Sum, Sum, sum, sum, Sum siin. See sama link siin. Copy link. Ma panen selle lingi siis. Praegult on niimoodi, et tegelikult tuleb sellele kuupäevale kaks ee, videot,
Õpetaja: Ee, ja kaks nii öelda. Linki.
Õpetaja: Ee, tänane kuupäev on siin. Ma korra Pastin ta siia. Control. Ta mõtleb suuremaks Üldse ka Mul ei Ole mitte midagi näha.
Õpetaja: Control B.
Õpetaja: Coopis siia Lingi ja tahab. Ma panen omasse veergu siia kõrvale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Videolink on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, see videohinko on olemas, aga sellega on üks. Aga
Õpetaja: kui seda proovida kasutada? Ma panen näiteks siit Copy
Õpetaja: kopi linki ja ma teen korra incognito nagu akna lahti, kus ma ei ole kuhugi sisse logitud
Õpetaja: Incognito Üritan seda kasutada,
Õpetaja: Siis ta ütleb, et recording is processing. Ühel hetkel ta tegelikult Siiski avab nagu videoakna, kus mängib Niiöelda siis video. Aga siis on niimoodi, et teil jääb ekslikult mulje, et see on üks video Tegelikult, Seal on kaks videot.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal selle pleieri juures. Noh, seda saab ka hästi natukene simuleerida. Ma võtan mingisuguse varasema. Ee, kuupäeva video, mis On olemas mõlemad videod.
Õpetaja: Teen miiting lahti. Vabandust, Recordings.
Õpetaja: Võtan, mida võtan eilse päeva eilse päeva. Linki on mul niikuinii vaja.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tuleksin Praegult võtaksin selle video siit nagu kogu video. Kui ma tulen siia sisse eilsele päevale, siis siin näitab, et tegelikult on siin kaks videot, Rekordi. Üks ja rekordi Kaks on nii.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma share in seda linki, mis on nagu Niukene üleüldine Coopi link või
Õpetaja: nii, ma Panen ta korraks kuskile siia. Plöraki maha.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen selle lahti,
Õpetaja: siis te nüüd näete ära. Põhimõtteliselt, et, ee, kuidas see asi Ee, Siis sellisel juhul toimib
Õpetaja: mass. Good on. See
Õpetaja: tuli. Aken lahti tuli.
Õpetaja: Mitu videot ta on?
Õpetaja: Tegelikult on kaks total Recordings, onju? Näete seda nuppu, Foward, et
Õpetaja: see paneb järgmise video käima. Nii et. Et, ee,
Õpetaja: mul on. Ma ütlen niimoodi. Vanasti ma ootasin, ootasin ja siis, kui Sain nagu selle vaate, kus sain kaks eraldi linki ja jagasin neid. Nüüd Ma teen niimoodi, et ma kohe panen nagu täna, nagu panen Ühe lingi, kus on mõlemad. Ja te saate neid mõlemaid vaadata. Selles mõttes pole probleemi. Lihtsalt panete play. Ja siis, kui tahate seda video kahte vaadata. Kohe siis loete. Forward
Õpetaja: või load. Ib paneb teise video. Vaata, tegelikult on kaks videot. Lihtsalt see Nextnupp on nagu Nüüd on nagu. Mine tagasi, vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii videosid saate vaadata. Probleeme pole. Ee, Siis pange tähele. Mis siin paremal on kõrval? Siin on download refils.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, miks siin on kolm faili? Tundub, et kaks videot, Kolm faili.
Õpetaja: Siin on lausa Selles mõttes niimoodi, et video ühel on Siis võimalik. Download I. Kui ma vaatan seda nuppu, siis me kokku. Lõpuks me lepime kokku. Keegi hakkab aitama ka selle asjaga kordamööda kas ka, onju,
Õpetaja: et kui video saab valmis, oleks hea, kui teeks nende kohta materjali. Ma juba tean. Siin mõned inimesed ongi olemas Kodexi ja Muude asjadega saab ka teha. Tegelikult, no problem,
Õpetaja: et kui vajutada download nuppu, siis see on see recording. Üks on, on ju
Õpetaja: video ise, Ta pakub, et Kas sa tahad videot alla salvestada? Mp, kolm, ee.
Õpetaja: Ei.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Automaatselt viskab järgmise faili lahti. Kas sa tahad ee audiofaili sellest asjast.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui korra. Igakord. Kui on Screen ära läinud, siis on kohe, et kuule me ei näe midagi. Audiofailiga vist ei ole ka midagi teha, on ju?
Õpetaja: Tead, videofail saate endale salvestada, näiteks ise, kui tahate alles hoida
Õpetaja: kuigi. Noh, siis pole vaja need säilivad väga, väga kaua. Need lingid töötavad? Nagu tõsiselt kaua, Cancel? Nüüd see viimane asi on see tegelikult Mis taga, Mida me taga ajame. Näete seda Recording Transkrip Vt. S on mingi formaat.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma olen sinna varaselt. Olen ka Download. In nagu näete,
Õpetaja: jah, ainuke, asi, mis ma olen Siis nagu muutnud on seda faili nimes. Nagu te näete, ma olen pannud siin mingi V, Üks ja V, kaks. Vaata, et igast on Video, üks ja video kaks. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ma olen tõmmanud ta täitsa ee siia kokku
Õpetaja: selle recording osa. Olen ära kustutanud ja pannud lihtsalt ee, Üks video, üks.
Õpetaja: Salvestan selle ära.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd Id järgi saaks teha. Teise video ka samamoodi. Läheme teise video peale,
Õpetaja: vaid on Download nuppu. Mina sa. Kui see video on juba ära renderdanud, siis on mul üks teine vaade, kus saab mõlemat eraldi vaadata. Saad konkreetselt minna Download I nagu mingi ee subtiitrifail. Mp. Neli on video cancel.
Õpetaja: M Neli ee A on audio cancel. Ei taha download Ida seda ee video Transcript Vdt.
Õpetaja: Jällegi download iks selle alla. Paned sellega video kaks?
Õpetaja: Ma panin sisekriipsuga niimoodi. Näiteks mõttes, saate aru?
Õpetaja: Nii põmm. Need on olemas,
Õpetaja: Ee, kuna need kaks videot on tegelikult ka nagu, ee, eraldi olemas. Ee, siis saaks vist juba. Kas see sama link töötaks ka? Ma Pakun.
Õpetaja: Ee, video üks. Ma korra tulen, võtan. Ma võtan nüüd jälle veel eraldi. Panen selle kinni. Teen korra uuesti lahti. Incognito. Akna. Vaata, Et kas, ee. Kas see link, mis ma sealt ülevalt võtan, Töötaks,
Õpetaja: kui ta läheb Küsibskoodi Noh, pääsk koodi peab teadma,
Õpetaja: aga pääskood on kohe. Seal ee. Alguses olemas seda, mida ma saan. Share Ida.
Õpetaja: Pääskohd on olemas.
Õpetaja: Watch Recording.
Õpetaja: Noh, viib konkreetselt sellele ühele videole,
Õpetaja: on ju Nii rekordiga, eks? Selles mõttes see informatsioon, mida oleks meil hakata vaja, nagu captureima niiöelda kinni püüdma. On olemas
Õpetaja: lihtsalt siis Kui see on juba ära renderdatud, siis. Ee. Vähemalt mina vist saan minna. Otse Zoom I ka.
Õpetaja: Ma saan panna. Need. Ma saan neid videolinke võtta natukene mugavamalt ühest kohast. Sellepärast, et. Aga see on ainult siis, kui video on juba ära renderdanud. Ma saan minna nagu sisse. Näed, siia päeva Mul hetkel ei ole midagi siin. Vaadata Processing Processing Processing, onju? See on tänane päev.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma võtan eilse päeva ja lähen otse Nagu päris video sisse.
Õpetaja: Siin. Mul on nüüd olemas nagu kenasti
Õpetaja: Copy Shareable Link Recording Ühe kohta
Õpetaja: Recordin kahe kohta. Shareble Link ja eraldi Saan näiteks audio transcript I downloadida. Siit. Siin on väiksed. Kui ta on kõik ära renderdanud, on juba veidi luksusem ja mul on see link olemas.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas teie nagu saate neile ligi või mitte, aga põhimõtteliselt videolingid Ja, ee, on kättesaadavad. Mina nüüd võtan selle Ee, rekordinga. Ühe eilsest päevast. Kakskümmend viis. Oot, vanasti. Ma vist tegin niimoodi. Vot mul tuleb meelde.
Õpetaja: Ee, lähme. Tagasi, Kus see on, Ee, siin Jah,
Õpetaja: ma tegingi Kus on need kuupäevad, millega me taidlesime? Siin niimoodi? Ee, kahekümne viiendal on kaks videot. Ma panen kontrol. Vee,
Õpetaja: ee Control V.
Õpetaja: Aga ma panin juba formaadi paika. See See asi töötas ka. Vaata, et pani õige kuupäeva. Vanasti
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on niimoodi et Mul on vaja seda linki
Õpetaja: korra. Et, Ee, panen siia ühe rea vahele, et mul on lihtsam tulla. Ma kopin selle lingi.
Õpetaja: Panen selle siia Zoomi videode alla. Tõstan siia eraldi lahtrisse ja selle, kust võtan siit ära. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Jälle vaid sa vaadat nuppu.
Õpetaja: Palun.
Õpetaja: Teen korra siia veel ühe rea vahele. Nüüd on teist veel vaja. See on tervele päevale sama.
Õpetaja: See on video üks
Õpetaja: ja minule meeldib nagu teha nagu normaalseks asju, et ma teen parema klõpsu selle peale. Või tähendab lihtsalt klõpsu selle peale. Ja siis selle Editiga. Ma panen selle mingi normaalse Nime
Õpetaja: Idea. Üks taustal on ikka see ring.
Õpetaja: Ma tean, sa teed selle teisega. Teen täpselt selle sama. Ütlen Copy Shareable link,
Õpetaja: Mul on siin üks rida ruumi. Vaata sellepärast, iga kord, kui sa kopeerid selle Share peal lingi ta paned tegelt kahel real. Ühel Real on videolink, Teisel Real on pääskaad. Nagu te näete, see pääskkaud juba kattub, onju? Ma saan selle lihtsalt ära kustutada selle
Õpetaja: ja sellest ma lihtsalt teeksin Nagu video kaks.
Õpetaja: Nii nüüd on siin olemas Kahekümne Viienda video üks ja kaks, ee, sordi juurde olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see asi, et mis teema Nendega on? On? Ju?
Õpetaja: On mul rekord. Pea ka on
Õpetaja: siis mis ma teen? Ma downloadisin need alla. Mul on need download kaustas,
Õpetaja: Ma kohe hakkan neid copima. Aga enne seda ma vaatan ühe Skill I juhendit. Korras ma enam ei mäleta.
Õpetaja: Loo Materjal mäletate seda loo. Uus õppematerjal küsis. Anna mingi teema. Me tegime Kit. Pruun või mida iganes katsetasime läbi tegi siia toksi alla. Teooriamaterjalid, mäletate?
Õpetaja: Nii? Nüüd on Midagi plaanis samasugust teha. Aga Nüüd on kasutame niukest killi nagu loo transcript. Ee, õppematerjal.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mida see asi teeb. No väga tiitel sisse ei lähe, aga mul on vaja vähemalt kataloogide asjade mõttes. Nagu aru saada.
Õpetaja: Loe video fail läbi ja koosta sellest algaja sõbralik õppematerjal eesti keeles. Salvesta see Step Ee sammud. Küsi kolme andmepunkt. Kolm andmepunkti. Videolink
Õpetaja: julgus videot vaadatakse. Video parool parool video avamiseks Kui on ja nüüd Anna lihtsalt transkrip Faili rada. Näiteks transcripts. Ja näete see samasugune fail,
Õpetaja: ta tahab. Ta Anna mulle transkript. Anna mulle videolink ja anna mulle parool ja ma teen sellest normaalse õppematerjali koos lingi ja parooli ja kõigega. Vaata, edaspidi saaks seda kasutada. Ee, tema vanasti oli Seda ma Pakun, et siis teeks samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Teeme ühe tausta siia juurde.
Õpetaja: Transcape,
Õpetaja: oota vastust. Enne kui jätkad. Ee, siis ta ise teeb ühe uue faili, Ise paneb ilusti formaadi videonumbri Bla blabla blabla, blabla, et tuleb Niukene videofail.
Õpetaja: See on Niukene. Ee, selline Kuupäeva formaat on see, mis on Järjestamissõbralik.
Õpetaja: Kui sa soovid Ee, faili faile salvest järjestada, Vaata kuupäevade ja mingi järgi, siis see töötab perfektselt. Vahet pole, Vaata, mis kuu mis aasta on.
Õpetaja: Loeb selle läbi. Ee, Ignoreeri mingeid asju, Analüüsi, sisu ja tuvasta teemad. Loe kogu tuvasta. Peamised teemad ja alateemad, millest räägitakse märgi ülesse iga teema Algusaeg sekundi täpsusega. Tead, ma olen ise teinud selle nagu mitte niimoodi taipinud, vaid lihtsalt öelnud, Claudia, et teeme niukse skill I
Õpetaja: tuvasta taaskinumbrite mainimised. Ee, tekstist B, Neli B, seitse õpetaja kolm ja mu es märgi. Nende täpne algusaeg mõista teemade loogiline järjekord ja seosed. Ja nüüd on parim. Asi. Vaata, otsi koodibaasist näite.
Õpetaja: Aa, otsi konkreetsed koodinäited, mis seonduvad teemadega,
Õpetaja: kui videotes Räägitakse. Voe komponentidest. Otsi Voefile Kui räägitakse Story Dest, Ma ei kasuta neid siin. Mingid näited. Põhimõtteliselt struktuurinõuded. Et lihtsalt ma olen. Ka. Ta tegi alguses mingisuguse konkreetse struktuuri, Aga ma siis ütlesin, et tee niimoodi, et alati on video parool
Õpetaja: ja diada ja hüperlingid teemade jaoks. Eraldi sektsioonid, stiilireeglid, salvesta fail teavita Kasutajat lõpus. Kogu asjast.
Õpetaja: Mingi niukene asi. Noh, mis ma siis tegema? Pean Ee, nüüd ma võtan. Lähen teen selle kataloogi lahti. Download tulen siia vajutan. Näed, siin on üks failis. On väikene erinevus. Siin on mingi.
Õpetaja: Mingi, üks ekstra. See, et teeme nad ühesuguseks.
Õpetaja: Võtan need mõlemad Failid, tulen siia, panen V
Õpetaja: Küsib, et kas siia kausta panen failid ja. Ja kas need on osa niiöelda projektist ja. Ja
Õpetaja: nüüd on olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma saaksin põhimõtteliselt siis teha Cloud Code lahti. Öelda. Noh, kohe kui ta lahti teeb,
Õpetaja: öelda Cloud,
Õpetaja: kui kellegil on kodeks, kodeksiga saab samamoodi teha. Saaks lihtsalt tulla siia peale. Vaata, nagu öelda, et. Ee, ma võin teha isegi pikalt. Ma saan ju teha niimoodi. Vaata, Skill
Õpetaja: loo. Ee, Mis on materjal?
Õpetaja: See? Ma saaks käivitada niimoodi Praegu Seda siis ta küsis kolm küsimust. Vaata, et anna mulle see, anna mulle. Too ja nii edasi, onju? Ee, mis ta küsis? Vaata, Ma võin korra veel vaadata. Ta küsib kolme asja. Ee, mis järjekorras Nad on
Õpetaja: videolink. Parool, transkripti rada. Ehk siis ta tahab teada, millise transkripti kohta.
Õpetaja: Videolink, palun. Videolink. Copy On See esimene teema on Ju Copy. Copy.
Õpetaja: Ma võin ka kohe peale tühikutele sisse panna. Ta saab aru,
Õpetaja: On õppematerjal. Või Ma saaks ka niimoodi öelda. Näiteks kui oleks kodeksi Kasutaja. Siis ma saaks öelda niimoodi. Vaata, otsiks Selle Skill I ülesse. Loovus, Õppematerjal panen Parem Klõps
Õpetaja: Ma ütleks. Käivitas. Kill,
Õpetaja: Käivitas küll. See.
Õpetaja: Ta saaks siis ka aru. Vaata, ma tegelikult saaks ka vaadata korra. Mis teksti mul siin on? Ee, loo materjal. Ta peaks siis ka sellest saama aru. Kunagi räägin sellest natukene rohkem,
Õpetaja: Aga praegult Mina olen Cloud Codiga, mitte Kodex. Ega mina teeksin seda niimoodi. Skill.
Õpetaja: Ee, transcript Materjal.
Õpetaja: Nüüd videolink.
Õpetaja: Tulen siia, vajutan. Copy link.
Õpetaja: Link on selline tühik. Siis ta tahab parooli. Võtan selle parooli.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd viimane. Asi. Ta tahab saada selle selle konkreetse niiöelda viide faile. Parem klõps,
Õpetaja: Copy Bath Reference Ja alati võtan see From Repository Root. Ehk siis sellest pankkataloogist Alates kopin selle siia, panen,
Õpetaja: tuli siia alla. Noh, ei paistnud kohe välja. Satume üldse aru,
Õpetaja: aga oleks ka saanud lihtsalt käivitada seda ja Ta ükshaaval küsib Ja Vastan nagu Kui teed seda iga päev, siis ei viitsi. Võtad entrit,
Õpetaja: Näed, Ta ütleb, et küsi nagu need Data Points Id. Aga ta juba ütleb, et sain lingi. Sain parooli. Sain paati. Vaata, ära tüüta mind
Õpetaja: nüüd. Ta lihtsalt teeb, aga see põhiline Asi, mis mulle meeldib ka on see, et ta nüüd vaatab. Koodibaasil näitab Ee, Miks sellepärast, et, ee, kui me iga päev tegelikult oleks iga päev isegi teha hea. Üks väike eraldi haru, video, üks ja video kaks. Kui me teeme lõunapausi.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et mis siis on, on see. Vaata, et. Ee. Mina teeksin niimoodi. Vaata, et kui me enne see kood muutub, kood kogu aeg muutub, on ju
Õpetaja: minu mõte on see, et. Ee, ega need transkripti need. Ee, Kui me vaatame, teeme transkripti lahti. Ega ta seda Eesti keelt väga hästi ikka ei Pane nagu mingi loed seda teksti. Nagu. Mida ma sa üldse peaks aru saama, et Jumala võssa paneb igatepidi soome keeles vä
Õpetaja: tugevasti vigane Suures Soome Eesti segakeel. Mõttetu masintõlge Kohandi Täiendatud kordustega. Arvu ei saa puhe. Mies. Sadu kordi suudad avata ainult üldised teemad nagu aga täpselt Selgitusega tsitaate. Kuidas soovid jätkata.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, no arvo ei saa. Sadu Kordi on aru. Ei saa, Puhemees Paned õige oopeni.
Õpetaja: Ee, oi, audio. Finish Original James. Limage.
Õpetaja: Ma võin siit selle ära panna, aga ma ei tea, kas ta, enam tagantjärgi midagi ee suudab Estonian.
Õpetaja: Kui midagi tegema hakkab. Ma tean, Ee, ma ei tea, kas ta üritab video järgi uuesti renderda. Näed transcribing?
Õpetaja: Okei, siis ma korra talle ütlen. Vaata, Chat about ist. Ee, Ma ütlen talle.
Õpetaja: Ee, jätame.
Õpetaja: Proovime teise failiga. Proovime teise fail. Seda teine oli eesti keeles.
Õpetaja: Ma Nüüd loodan, et oskab Eesti võidelda. Ma ei tea, kuidas Zoom on teinud, et kas see hakkab nüüd video audiotoetlust uuesti tegema läbi ja Proovime seal teksti või mitte, Will, See hea proovimees.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt seda Ja põhimõtteliselt sada sadu kordi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ütleme proovime Teise Ee
Õpetaja: videolink.
Õpetaja: Ee videolink.
Õpetaja: Mm, kus mul oli Excelis oli see lahti.
Õpetaja: Ee, see siin.
Õpetaja: Videolink.
Õpetaja: Parool on sama.
Õpetaja: Ja mis ta veel tahab? Videofail.
Õpetaja: No hea, et ütles seda. Vaata, ee. Selles mõttes, onju?
Õpetaja: Loeme nii.
Õpetaja: Ma korra vaatan siis ka seda. Faili
Õpetaja: Minge. Nüginen pilves mobili ja punane mummu kana,
Õpetaja: Ta vist räägib midagi sellest. Pilve. Mummuste recording. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee. Vaatame korra eesti keeles. Paneme siis Screenshare. Okei, ma mõtlesin, ee, paar asja, mida teha. Ee, piinlik lugu on see. Ee,
Õpetaja: Ohoo. Varsti ütleb, et Kuule, mine nagu sinna kuskile Seda Seda on võimalik välja juurida neid eesid, Aga see nõuab mingi rämedat tööd. Ilmselt.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis ta räägib. Nüüd siis. Ee, sisu.
Õpetaja: Suurepärane, Väga sisukas. Cs I selektorid ja teema loen läbi ka viima. Noh, nüüd ta juba saab panna nagu selle teise videoga
Õpetaja: ja ta sellest. See kokkulepe ongi, et Ta teab, et ta otsib seda videoformaati selle, et ta võtab nime. Siit ta saab normaalse kuupäeva kätte
Õpetaja: ja tead. Ja tead, ja. Ja.
Õpetaja: Ja ta teeb selle valmis Ja ta topib selle siis eraldi kausta. Ee, ja siis saame vaadata, mida sellega võiks võibolla edasi teha, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta loob juba Õppematerjali faili nimi on Siuke Kuupäeva. Ta võtab sealt videonumber. On kaks. Ta võtab sellest v kahest
Õpetaja: ja põhimõtteliselt teeb niukse faili nime
Õpetaja: See oleks nagu jälle mõtte koht. Vaata, kas võibolla ta võiks olla hoopis ademel,
Õpetaja: et mäletate. Me tegime materjali. Html is on veits, Ee, lihtsam,
Õpetaja: aga samas on. Ee. Järgmine koht, kuhu me selle paneme, on jälle parem. Ta on Md.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: seni kaua, kuni tema seda teeb. Ee, või ma ei tea, kas proovime ära oodata või mitte? Lähen teen selle Koha lahti. Natukene. Võibolla mul Hakkab. See asi lapesse minema. Siin on nagu liiga palju asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, valige kontod. Jätame selle ülesse poole. Aa, tähtsamad teemad võiks olla siin ka Kuulge, ärge siis ära Unustage, onju. Palun vaadake neid teemasid.
Õpetaja: See on teie enda jaoks, mitte minu jaoks.
Õpetaja: Minul ei ole vaja neid mõned teemad, selge? Tuleb
Õpetaja: Ee, Nii, ee, ma panen natukene kinni. Zoom I mul. Kas meil tänast videot veel ei saa? Aa, tänase videolingi saab ära panna. Ikkagi,
Õpetaja: ee, et kui keegi tahab seda vaadata ee, näiteks ee. Jaanik
Õpetaja: vaadata, siis ta saab seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ma loodan, et ta siis teab, kuidas seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja Rita kirjutas ka vaene abi kanalisse. Vaata, siis viskame sinna info ka.
Õpetaja: Nii. Proovime. Ee, selle lingi. Ma võtan copilink.
Õpetaja: Ee, Teen lahti, selle. Vali idee.
Õpetaja: Täna on kahekümne. Kuues onju.
Õpetaja: Ma kustutan igaks juhuks selle ära.
Õpetaja: Kustutan ja teised asjad ka ära, teen lihtsalt uuesti.
Õpetaja: Need kaks esimest võiksid olla õiged.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, panen siia selle. Kustutan korra kindluse mõttes ära. Control V. Mul tundub, et oli õige Link.
Õpetaja: Nii, siin on see. Siin on see
Õpetaja: natukene väiksemaks. Need käsitletud teemad saab lühemaks teha. Panen selle nimeks lihtsalt, ee, video üks ja Kaks,
Õpetaja: et on, siis see on siis teil vihje? Vaata, on ju,
Õpetaja: et see on See üks ling, kus saab nagu edasi vaadata, et Kui ma olen pannud, et selles mõttes nüüd on niimoodi, et vanasti oli see, et ma ootasin, Ootasin, kuni nad renderdavad ja siis mingi Hetk läksin nagu need kuskil Aga siis tuleb elu sisse ja õhtu aja midagi ununeb. Ja keegi on pärast hommikul pahane et oleks tahtnud vaadata, et aidake mul meeles hoida, et enne, kui üldse Ma ära lähen, et ma panen
Õpetaja: selle üldise lingi ära,
Õpetaja: siis igaüks saab ise käia piilumas. Vaata, et kas on ära Refresh. Ind või mitte, Ta on suht mingi tunnikene kaks. Peale. Põhimõtteliselt päeva lõppu on tavaliselt valmis Jõutagi parasjagu koju
Õpetaja: saate vaadata, kui vaja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Nopooki Lm I videod. Vaatame korra, kas tema ikka siin toimetab? Noh, tal on päris kõvasti teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen nüüd ta natukene. Tab alt. Kinni. Kui palju natukene?
Õpetaja: Ee Võiksime seda ka proovida? Vaatame korra, millega on tegemist Google Oma kontoga saab sisse minna.
Õpetaja: Let S. Go. Minul on näiteks mingi varasemast ajast. Valid. D. Kolmkümmend üheksa.
Õpetaja: Vaatan, kas sul. Mul on mingisugune Mingisugused materjalid ja asjad seal all. Saan uue notebook I teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, natuke palju on isegi neid siin.
Õpetaja: Mingid teemad. Mingi hetk. Ma üritasin tagantjärgi neid teha. Aga see on lihtsalt täiesti Mission Impossible. Kui saad ainult kolm videot päevas teha. Aga näiteks see töötab niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: te Valite siit tekst, teksti, dokumendid, Lihtsalt lühikokkuvõte.
Õpetaja: See sama, mida me praegu niiöelda siin toimetame ja teeme,
Õpetaja: et ee see töötab niimoodi, et sa Saad valida konkreetsed teemad või andmed. Ja kui sa valid näiteks ühe asja, siis sa saad, öelda. Et. Kuule, tee mulle video over you,
Õpetaja: Tee mulle video väikene. Niiöelda Näiteks siin on mingi jaava. Ta nüüd pealkirjadest valib. Ise. Vaata, onju, et siin on näiteks mingi, on siis Umbes selline, asi
Õpetaja: kui sul on näiteks mingi seadustik või mingi asi. Ja seal on mingid teemad ja asjad. Vaata, et on omavahel seotud, Siis on nagu mingi niuke asi, millega sa saad väga mugavalt Nagu mingi pildi, ette et mis siin on Näiteks tahad õppida mingit asja, Siis Saad nagu hakata sinna sisse minema.
Õpetaja: Saad sealt sellest materjali otsida? Ta viitab kohe nagu päris materjalide. Kus sa oled päris Niukene Hea asi, kui on mingisugune keeruline värk, mida sa pole varem kokku puutunud. Saad mingi üldse pildi? Aga paremad asjad on näiteks. Ee. See video Overview paned käima? Tema ise on teinud. Noh, ma kõlari. Nüüd saan siin põhja panna või mitte
Õpetaja: endal maas üldse.
Õpetaja: Mingi uus sünd peaks video õppida. Ei, see on. See on täiesti teistsugune mõõteviis. Lähme vaatame, mida ma silmas pean.
Õpetaja: Ise teeb Nagu mingid visuaalid asjad käigu pealt Mingeid reegleid pole
Õpetaja: on nagu arhitekt. See ei luba sul ühtegi telliski panna enne kui sul on ette näidata korralik detailne joonis, see joonis Ongi jaava maailmas klass.
Õpetaja: Ja vot see ongi See esimene suur nihe, mis su peas läheb. Toimuma java. See ei ole kohta improviseerimisele absoluutselt Iga pisemgi detail. See tuleb ette ära defineerida.
Õpetaja: Kõik peab olema paigas, enne kui sa isegi mõtled koodi käivitamisele,
Õpetaja: näiteks see Ink versus mõtle sellest inktist, kui. Noh, lihtsalt numbrist. Näiteks viis, mis on paberile kirjutatud otse ja ausalt kerge, kiire aga selga kõik,
Õpetaja: aga see on juba nagu Väike karbike. Sees on see number viis, Aga karbil endal on ka igasugu lisavõimalusi küljes. Ja mis on eriti eriti oluline,
Õpetaja: See karp Võib olla ka täiesti tühi. Ja see on see kuulus nutt. Okei, aga nüüd nüüd tuleb üks asi, millest sa pead tõesti aru saama, Kui sa tahad javas ellu jääda, see on see kuidas Java tegeleb mäluga,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes, et see video on tehtud siis nagu mingist materjali pealt. Mina kindlasti niimoodi midagi ei äppinud. Seal sellisel kujul. Vaata, võibolla ei äppki siin. Sa soovid jamas ellu jääda,
Õpetaja: aga see selles mõttes on tegelikult üliodav. Viis Vaata, kuidas tegelikult saada mingisugust Nagu asja. Et et seda, saab nagu kombineeritult kasutada. Vaata, on ju, et et Meil on need materjalid, mida tegelikult peaks läbi töötama. Mida just ta genereerib? Võibolla valmis näinud,
Õpetaja: aga enne, seda võibolla hoopis vaadata see video Ära
Õpetaja: vaata, genereerib selle video. Vaatad selle video? Sa saad mingisuguse üldise, mingisuguse pildi sellest asjast ette. Ee, seal, kuidas tema nagu neid näiteid toob ja nii edasi. Ja siis sa loed seda natuke tehnilisemat teksti. Vaata, sa hakkad noppima välja neid nagu väikseid nüansse mida sinna viosse Lihtsalt Ei, mahtunud.
Õpetaja: Noh, samamoodi. Ma ütlen, et siin on valijaga teema. Vaata onju. Ja pane näiteks. Ee, kas siin on kuskil podcast ka Nagu mingit vana hakkavad mingi Mul lihtsalt podcast. I pole. Ma võin ruttu võtta või? Me vaatame korra, kas äkki nüüd on, Nagu näed tehtud.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra, mis ta siis tegi. Kus me leiame ruttu selle faili ülesse. Ta lõi mingi uue faili. Lähed tool i alla Unversion File.
Õpetaja: Tirime selle muidugi versioneerituks. Kus ta tegelikult on, on? Tuleb siia ka osta.
Õpetaja: Teeb selle lahti, Vaatab siit visuaalse tööriistaga. Kui Life, vaata Videot. Link on olemas Online. Klikid. Sellele
Õpetaja: läheb kohe siia. Kui ei ole nagu sisse logitada ega midagi. Ta võib parooli küsida. Tuled kopid sellest samast parooli ja paned, onju Play, Kõik on olemas. Saad vaadata, Kui seda oleks vaja. Ei ole vaja sisukord.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta pani ise teemat kotta. Kit, Kuidas õpetajale kiirelt järgi jõuda. Haru nimetab see tavad ja tiketi. Numbridge Rainbow Brackets I koodi su sugulussuhted ja ja ta Annab sulle need kellaajad ka ära
Õpetaja: või? Noh, videominutil,
Õpetaja: et sa tahad vaadata Cssi selektoreid asjad ja nüüd on see ka. Vaata, ärge unustage ära, et see on ju algajale
Õpetaja: töötada või midagi. Ja on. Ta teeb valesti. Hea küll. Ma otsin korra.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin ta on, kontrolli F. Iga saab üles leida niikuinii. Seda tuleb vaadata. Tal on siin taustal. On tal midagi natukene sassis seal,
Õpetaja: mis ta räägib, et mis asi. See Css on. Vaata, otsib üles. Vaata, meil elemendid rakendab neid Stiile, on Peame koolmiste selektortüüpi.
Õpetaja: Mingi skeem on siin välja toodud, et Kõige ebatäpsem mõjutab kõiki kõige täpsemalt. Mäletate, rääkisime sellest ju.
Õpetaja: Siin On mingi koodinäitajad projektist Auston Green, Ausson Purple Noh Aa, see on see
Õpetaja: Kui hea, nagu te Mõtlen. Nagu et. Vaata, kui vanasti oli. Veel Nagu mingeid nagu vabandusi. Vaata, et mingit asja ei saa nagu selgeks õppida. Vaata, nüüd saad ainult iseennast süüdistada. Kõik on olemas. Tee see tee video.
Õpetaja: Noh Ee, võibolla isegi võiks mõelda veel ee teisigi kohti Nagu, ee, on siukene platvorm, kus saab teha Powerpoint Presentatsiooni Samamoodi Annad mingi staffidele. Ette Ütled, et
Õpetaja: teeme kümne kümne slaidiline presekas onju aga Noh, ma arvan, et see video on üks parimaid asju, mis on,
Õpetaja: et enne kui hakkad vaatama seda asja No ma saan proovida ju, Ee, panen panen tegema.
Õpetaja: Ee, valid. Ee, lähme siit välja. Great Notebook.
Õpetaja: Panen uue noteboot I. Nime. Mul on väga palju tuttavaid, kes kasutavad seda nagu igast asjadeks. Sul on mingid dokumendid, Paberid. Viska need sisse Chati, räägi.
Õpetaja: Ee, mingid mõttematerjalid. Flash kaart, Teate, Flash, kaart küsimus ühel Pool vastus teisel pool
Õpetaja: jaadi ja mingi See kogu aeg tuleb igast asju juurde. Ma ei jaksa isegi siin Ee, olla.
Õpetaja: Ee, untijdel Notebook. Vali, ma oli It.
Õpetaja: Ee, nelikümmend. Üks. Vaata, neljakümne esimene lend. Mitte minu neljakümne esimene lend. Ad source. Vali mingisugune fail. Noh mis? No problem. Aken lahti.
Õpetaja: Ee, kõrvale.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, seda ma ei taha. Ma tahan ee seda transcript materials Md.
Õpetaja: Noh, seda on ju?
Õpetaja: Siia olen, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, kas ta praegu kuidagi üritas Browseriga seda hoopis lahti teha? Ee, siia Upload files.
Õpetaja: Aa. Okei. Seda saab ka kasutada. Ma Ühe Korra proovin veel peaks panema. Täpselt siia kasti.
Õpetaja: Vot nii loeb selle sisse. Üsna mahukas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on. See on Selected.
Õpetaja: Siin on juba mingi sisu, siis sa saad chat ida Sellega sa saad sellel teemal.
Õpetaja: Noh, materjalidel on sees. Tahad, tahad midagi rääkida? Selle vahe on nagu see, et notebook. Il Notebook Lem Il on see, et hallutsinatsioonid võtame ära. Ee, selles mõttes, et. Ee. Kui sina hakkad midagi tavalise chat iga suhtlema, siis ta väga palju võtab asju oma treenitud andmete pealt ja mudeli peal.
Õpetaja: Kui sa annad talle sisu ette, vaata, siis on nagu See, et kuule nüüd on sinu info, on siin.
Õpetaja: Kasutame sinu nagu mõistust et, siin nagu enamvähem prediktida vaata. Mis, on õige ee, Järgmine, nii öelda, Silvikene, Ütleme, siis tee mulle ära. Aga see suhtlus on juba nende andmete najal.
Õpetaja: See on mugav, et sa võid seal toppida neid nii palju, kui tahad. Iga kord sa saad seda Selectida. Vaata, et mille kohta sa üldse midagi nagu tahad vaadata nagu või arutleda Hästi, Nagu mõnus keskkond.
Õpetaja: No Mina praegu lihtsalt selekin selle ja ütlen, et, ee, tee mulle podcast Deep type brief kritik, debate.
Õpetaja: Noh, detive, Language lengt.
Õpetaja: Noh, Aa, Default. Ja ma arvan, et short on siis lühem. Vaata, las talle vaikimise peal.
Õpetaja: Saad veel midagi siin mainida, näiteks Et Mida, millele? Nagu podcasti inimesed peavad fokusseerima.
Õpetaja: Näiteks, sul on mingid teemad. Vaata, mis sinu jaoks on. Nagu segasemad, Eriti see mis ma Olen terve päeva teemad või? Noh, poole päeva. Teemad. On ju, et, ee. Juba. Ta ise pakub ka, et kompeer mingi Css.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta Pakub ise küsimusi ka. Vaata, siin onju, et saad kirjutada, midagi. Aga põhimõtteliselt võid ka tühjaks jätta. Vaata, on ju et ta, lihtsalt siis teeb.
Õpetaja: Vajutad Channereid, Hakkab seda tegema.
Õpetaja: Näed, on siin, ma olen. Ma ütlen, et teed sellest videooverview. Ka
Õpetaja: mina ei tea, siin ma nagu Midagi kunagi ei ole muud valinud.
Õpetaja: No valime siis pulli pärast, et midagi Papercraft.
Õpetaja: Whiteboard, siis läheb. See
Õpetaja: Kuidas on nagu Niuke tehniline asi, Ma ise jätaks ta nagu lihtsalt mingi neutraalseks. Jälle mingit dopikut sai küsida? Vaata, on ju? Nüüd ta genereeri. No see võtab aega, et hiljem Päeva lõpus Tuleme. Vaatame nii kaua ei võta. Muidugi,
Õpetaja: aga mõte on siis olemas, nagu, et et kui te saate ise tegelikult oma, Teil on kõik antud. Teil on video. Palun mine vaata. Jäi midagi ebaselgeks. Kuule, kuidas ma jäpin seal vana käsku. Kiiruses on kaks, on ju
Õpetaja: enne seda. Võibolla siis ma ütlen, kui on juba genereeritud. Vaata, nagu see Md Fail. Väga hea, kui mitte, kui sul Cloud on Või mida iganes, saad ka ise seda genereerida.
Õpetaja: Ee, jaadi. Ja mine. Notebook Lm I Rega seal konto Ära Google ga Logid sisse. See On Google oma. Tule, vali video Tule, vali audio. Kuula, vaata paar korda läbi. Võibolla, nagu,
Õpetaja: noh, justkui niimoodi. Veel korrata. Näiteks õhtul. Lihtsalt korra kiirelt vaadata üks video ära, et nagu oleks Fresh meeles, saad mõelda loomulikult ideaalis, siis tegelikult ideaalis võiks üldse olla siis see, et, Ee, tegelikult pigem nagu
Õpetaja: pigem nagu hakata. Nagu vaatama neid asju. Vaata, see on nüüd eriti siis, kui te ei osalenud tunnis, on ju, et ei jõua võibolla kõike vaadata, onju? Siis te tulete, vaatate seda
Õpetaja: videomaterjali?
Õpetaja: Olete enne kuulnud ennem natukene näinud ja nüüd üritate lugeda seda teksti. Vaata, jah, siin on üksjagu pikk asju. Aga siin on näi päriselu. Analoogiad
Õpetaja: Tiketinumber on nagu isikukood. Igaühel on oma unikaalne number, mida ei anta kunagi. Teisele inimesele uuesti, isegi kui inimene kaob. Näiteks tiket suletakse.
Õpetaja: See See on tšillipilli. On siin.
Õpetaja: Sellest kokkuvõttes Video otsa. Lõpuks Ma Ei, tea, uuri.
Õpetaja: Oo, nii et sa mõtled, et Cloud Count kohe paneb sinna nagu vä
Õpetaja: võib proovida. Ma pole. Ma ei teadnud, Kas Ta videot laseb? Vaata, vaatame ajatus. Orses
Õpetaja: Upload files. Näe, audio and More. Ta ei maini otset videot. Vaata, aga Vaatame tüüpide alt. On Ikka, jah.
Õpetaja: Jaa, miks mitte ma pole kunagi proovinud? Aga seal võib juhtuda see muidugi. Mis sa ütlesid. Oled mingi ressursi Ee piirangud, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: Aga nad. Vaata, siin on see erisus. Vaata, et miks. Nagu see minu variant on parem. Vaata sellepärast, et ma olen palunud Selle koodinäited ja asjad, mis on otse koostis. Vaata, on ju nagu. Mis? Mida me leiame läbi ja arutanud, aga. Aga printsiibis muidugi
Õpetaja: seda Mõtlesin, et siin on nagu. Noh, elu on läinud. Lihtsalt Mina ei tea. Koolitajad kaotavad varsti töö. Mine pane
Õpetaja: palun. Lõpeta, mind, Annan teemad asjad videod välja. Kõik on
Õpetaja: ikka võimalik, tegelikult, et see jääb ainult ee. Iseenda taha Jääb lõpuks, et
Õpetaja: tead arvatavasti arvatavasti niukeste asjadega, kui Palju nüüd villast? Ikka seda materjali on? Mingid lademetest. Need mudelid on suht täpsed. On ju, et
Õpetaja: Ee, et, noh, ta ei lähe niikuinii sellest nagu nii süvitsi. Vaata, et vaatame nüüd mingi kolmekümne, niiöelda realist koodi ja mingi arutleme. Vaata seda niikuinii siin ei ole, on ju
Õpetaja: Aga aga isegi printsiibis, kui oleks. Ma arvan, et ega seal saaks ka nad suuresti hakkama Nagu, et mingi õpetamise mõttes
Õpetaja: ma arvan, et Suht kvaliteetne. Staff tuleb välja või? Noh, piisavalt Okei, kvaliteet arvestades. Siis seda, vaata et mis ressursi sa ise pead sinna sisse panema, on peaaegu olematu, onju, et
Õpetaja: lihtsalt küsi. Räägi, tee.
Õpetaja: Jah, ma ei tea, see on see sama jah,
Õpetaja: see on lihtsalt eelmisest kursusest mingi naine, Nagu me näeme, pärast ka häält, ei saa minu meelest valida. Iga kord on Random ilt, et kas on mees või naine,
Õpetaja: et ee, et uurige.
Õpetaja: Ja, noh, ütlen, et ega meil on ka võimalus, et laseme selle asja natukene sett ida. Ma olen veidi aega võinud seda kuidagi ise teha. Aga pigem on printsiibis nagu see. Vaata, et ee. Saaksime kuidagi veidi jaotada, et see muutub nagu see on nii vähe tegevusi, Aga see on palju tegevusi ühele inimesele. Lähme kordamööda. Võibolla
Õpetaja: protsessid on ja pilves.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Meile. Ka Nagu
Õpetaja: teil on juurdepääs te lihtsalt Samamoodi näete Renderda Render. Ma saan selle lingi anda teile ühel hetkel. Lihtsalt, ee. Kui vajutad. Refresh on järsku põmm video on ees ja Sealt ma ütlen, et sealt on võimalik kõik kätte saada. Videod on võimalik kätte saada. Heli on võimalik kätte saada. Videotranskriptid on võimalik kätte. Saada
Õpetaja: serveris.
Õpetaja: See päris ei kumiti ka nende panidega.
Õpetaja: Kuidas teed kummiti ka nende failiga
Õpetaja: ja teen Ee, aga enne seda, kui ma siis Ma teen nüüd ettevalmistust. Me läheme kohe edasi asjadega.
Õpetaja: Ma teen ee, selle indeksi saate. Te peate nüüd kõik järgi tulema, selles mõttes, et Ee, te võite sealt juba Clearida või commitida, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Aa, oota. Mitte videolink, vaid Ee,
Õpetaja: Ee, Me saadame hoopis selle lingi ju siin On ju kõik olemas, nii?
Õpetaja: Ja siia ma ütlen, et ma idee järgi ei oleks idee. Ma ütlen, et see. Notebooki lemmik Me saame pärast katsetada. Me ei taha seda tunni ajal teha.
Õpetaja: Seal on niimoodi, et sa saad Share ida neid linke ja asju. Ee, aga ikkagi on probleem, et keegi ei saa kuidagi väga ligi. Ja teine asi on see, et sa saad teha ainult kolm, kolm videot korraga,
Õpetaja: et Ta Ei, luba nagu niimoodi. Et sa iga päev käivitad ja genereerid video juurde, et kokku on kolm slot i
Õpetaja: ee päevas saad põhimõtteliselt Kas Ühe või kaks videot. Midagi taolist. Kuidagi oli niimoodi. Ja nad on ikkagi üritanud seda, et, noh, osta ikkagi see subscription ja mis iganes, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, aga mina olen nagu niimoodi teinud, et ma olen lihtsalt Youtubei pannud,
Õpetaja: et kui me tahame nagu teha neid notebooki videosid Ja niimoodi, et need oleks kõigile kättesaadavad. Tekitan Google Drive S mingisuguse kausta, kus keegi saab siis näiteks selle video ära renderdada, teistele panna Panen Ee, panen Youtube ja siis on link. Mis on For Life,
Õpetaja: et võib mõelda.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, vaatame, kuidas läheb.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ma väga väga Ei, Ei, kasuta siin nagu isikukoodiga, bla, blabla ja, noh, niukest asja, et
Õpetaja: mis siin on? Ee, ei muidu nagu selles mõttes, muidu, kas nagu Peab notebook Lm I kartma, vä?
Õpetaja: Ma ei. Ma ei ole nagu selles mõttes terms and Condition It vaadanud, et, ee, mis on seal nagu sätestatud. Ee, Selles osas ma pakun, et seal mingisugused ee. Mingisugused niiöelda turvalisuse aspektid selles mõttes ja lubadused on, juures, sest inimesed viskavad sinna dokumente.
Õpetaja: Mm, et, ee. Aga ma ei ole uurinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma arvan, et tegelikult varem või hiljem kogu aeg on see konfidentsiaalsuse asi Loomulikult mingi panga asju nagu sinna ei tasuks toppida. Ja mingeid, ee, inimese mingeid delikaatseid. Mingi Medical Stuff I nagu Ei, tahaks, nagu vaata On ju?
Õpetaja: Aga ma arvan, et absoluutselt koguaeg koguaeg. Kui me räägime mingist arendustest ja asjadest ka oma ettevõttega ja nii edasi, kogu aeg Põrkame selle vastu. Vaata aga, see konfidentsiaalsus. Vaata, jaga nagu see, et kõik, mis sa paned sinna kujul Põhimõtteliselt läheb ju. Noh, pilve ka Ja bla, blabla onju.
Õpetaja: Aga ma arvan, et nagu, et esiteks. Ega need ettevõtted, kes, ee, kes pakuvad neid teenuseid, ega nad niisama kuskil Neid ise ei jaga. Nad niikuinii Annavad endast parima, et nad kuskile ei leki. Miks See on nende usaldusväärsus? Ju Ei taha kasutada,
Õpetaja: et Ma arvan, et nagu varem või hiljem peavad nii ettevõtted, kui ka asutused leppima sellega, et, ee, kui nad tahavad niimoodi mugavalt neid asju kasutada. Ee, siis siis See ongi teadlik risk. Vaata, et jah
Õpetaja: need lähevadki kolmandale osapoolele. Aga kas nad satuvad tingimata nüüd kuskile mingi teistele ettevõtetele vabaks kasutamiseks. Kindlasti ei ka isegi salaja. Mitte sellepärast, et ma arvan, et ei, ega ei soovi endale seda, et et nemad on Nii nagu jaganud meie mingeid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Sest et. Noh, siis ju keegi ei taha enam enda teenuseid tarbida.
Õpetaja: Ja loomulikult on siis muidugi võimalik Ka kohalikud mudelid oma arvutis oma serveris. Noh, siis kaitse nii hästi ära. Kui oskad Ja
Õpetaja: ongi kogu jutt nagu, et, aga ma kuulan hästi. Palju. Nii palju on nagu seda. See Mingi tohutu hirm on. Nagu ma ise koguaeg mõtlen. Nagu, et kas mina kardan nagu oma isikukoodi ja sinna Chat sse panna. Mis asja ta ütleb, et ära tee seda. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kas ma kardan siin oma mingi pangakonto numbrit panna ja muid asju. Noh, paroole Ma ei hakkaks sinna toppima. See on nagu kindel, seda ma nagu väldiks
Õpetaja: aga aga kõik niuksed, muud asjad, mis muidu võibolla võiksid ka olla mingisugused ründe vektorid, et kuidagi mind võibolla saboteerida. Aa, mingi midagi, midagi kuidagi neid andmeid kasutades mul midagi välja õngitseda. See risk on alati olemas, Aga mul ikkagi on mingisugune usaldus,
Õpetaja: et vähemalt nagu nad väga leebelt, nagu neid asju Kuidagi välja ei jaga. Muidugi, Mingi Häkker võib ikka sisse
Õpetaja: kuskile tungida ja triljonites Ee, ridades andmeid kuhugi kõrvale kantida, vaata, et, noh, see on see risk, Aga ma ei kavatse sellepärast jätta oma nagu normaalset elu elamata. Et nagu tšillipillid tegutseda, on, ju
Õpetaja: et, ee, et see Niimoodi on, aga see on hästi. See on. See on keeruline probleem. Tegelikult,
Õpetaja: et tahaks ju kõiki neid asju kasutada, aga ei tohi
Õpetaja: nii, Ee, minul on plaanis vaadata korra. Ee, siit harumajanduse alt Ee masterit.
Õpetaja: Ja ma tahan näha viimast Aa Põhimõtteliselt, mis oli, Ee, Lubasin korra näidata.
Õpetaja: Üks Asi mida ma ei ole näidanud. Teil üks töövõte.
Õpetaja: Kui teil on mitu erinevat haru või on mingid kommit Id,
Õpetaja: näiteks see Sama indeks Atml praeguses seisus. Mina saan näiteks praegu teha parema klõpsu panna. Kit
Õpetaja: ja Compare with branch
Õpetaja: siit remote I alt. Ma võiks Nagu vaadata, et. Hei, mina olen selle asja niimoodi teinud. Aga vaatame, kuidas Aivar tegi selle asja
Õpetaja: ja siis ta näitab nagu erinevusi ühel Pool on õpetaja. Teisel pool on. Ee. Niiöelda aivar. Siin on nagu mingisugused abistavad värvid ja asjad, mis üritab nagu veits highlightida. Aa, vahel on parem lihtsalt kõik Highlight Id korra maha võtta ja vaadata lihtsalt oma silmaga. Vot see on. Noh, niigi on kirju juba
Õpetaja: et saad vaadata, näiteks. Noh, teie siis pigem minu haru vastu. Näiteks, kui tahaks vaadata, saaks teha niimoodi. Eeldab seda, et ma olen ära kommitind ja Push Ind. Ja teie olete teinud, onju Muidu te vaatate mingi vana seisu vastu ja on ka võimalik vaadata nagu faile, näiteks erinevate kommitide vastu Sellel failil see failil tegelikult on. Aja jooksul vist
Õpetaja: tulnud. Vist Kaks komitee või kolm. Ma ei tea tegelt rohkem,
Õpetaja: kui ma vaatan, Näiteks nüüd Ja Revision. Ehk Ma tahan vaadata mingi varasema ee asja vastu
Õpetaja: Ma tahan vaadata Näiteks pomm esialgselt. See fail nägi välja selline.
Õpetaja: Mina hiljem. Lisasin juurde mingid kommentaarid asjad.
Õpetaja: No täna see on tänane seis. Ma võin ma vaadata ka niimoodi, nagu, et, ee, mis ta oli mul näiteks. Ee.
Õpetaja: Just, ee, eelmise. Niiöelda selle ee. Komiitiga. Ehk siis revision. Näed, eelmise vastu
Õpetaja: olen siin. Noh, mingi paar muudatust on, Saate aru, saate kõike vaadata niimoodi, kui kui tahate.
Õpetaja: Ja. Aga mina tahan. Ee, tahtsingi tegelikult teha seda, et öelda, et hei, milline ta Oli alguses, enne kui me hakkasime siin mässama. Ee. Otsin selle kõige alumise
Õpetaja: ja võtan siit. Control a Copy Control, C. Basted.
Õpetaja: Tahan, et Ta oleks täpselt nii, nagu ta. Oli Ma selle ära
Õpetaja: koos nende teiste failidega. Ja siis panen komitiks. Panen? Alustame uue asjadega.
Õpetaja: Nii te Võite ka nüüd tulla järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, teil on siin piisavalt palju aega. Ma ütlen kohe, kui see buss on tehtud sellepärast et taustal
Õpetaja: hakkame vaatama Natukene materjale.
Õpetaja: Me hakkame vaatama. Mis kuradi asi see voe veel on?
Õpetaja: Ee, ah, okei, siin on veel mõned asjad ka Siin on See kuskil see ee tingimused. Las ta ei tulla. Mäletate, Me tegime eraldi lehe. Tingimused. Loore. Ipsum läks sinna sisse. Vaata, mingi põhimõtteliselt,
Õpetaja: ee, tekst.
Õpetaja: Kohe Varsti räägime sellest ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma tahaks korra vaadata Confluence I asju, aga oli. Idee
Õpetaja: Me hakkame kohe varsti taas ka tegema ka. Ahaa, teeme nüüd niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: võtame siis õpetaja. Te võtsite kohe haru just praegu.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, võtke selle õpetaja pealt uus aru, aga Seekord pange natuke teistsugune nimi. Ma mängin selle ka läbi.
Õpetaja: Võtan õpetaja pealt haru tee. Pange oma nimi sidekriips ja teeb neli.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui tahate? Võite panna sinna V ühe juba juurde.
Õpetaja: Võib ka pärast lihtsalt olla. V, Kaks ja V kolme, ja nii, edasi, mida iganes nüüd On Tähtis on see, et me hakkame arendust taaski tegema. Me hakkame arendust tegema ja me kasutame seal taaski nimelist haaru.
Õpetaja: Teeb meili
Õpetaja: ära õhku, mis sa arvad?
Õpetaja: Pange kõik õpetaja Peep neli. Kes esimesena. Kes esimesena aru ära pushib. See saab ära push. Ida. Teistel on lihtsalt Puuga ei saa kõik panna sama nime, aga. Ja ei, see on väga tore. Ee, Sellepärast, et. Noh, mul on õ sõber Ville mereadruga, Vaatan pildi peal.
Õpetaja: Tema tegelikult osales selle. Sama Online koolituse mingi testgrupis seal paari inimest, nagu osalesin ja siis oli ma vaatasin, et mu sõber. Ma teadsin, et ta on rumal, aga ma ei teadnud, kui rumal ta on.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal oli niimoodi. Vaata, kirjelduses oli, et palun Tehke üks uus haru. Vaata, et pane siia oma nimi. Vaata ja siis ka mingisugune. Noh, midagi seal oli veel kirjas. Mingi taskunumber või nädala Number Sprindi number, sprint, üks, mis iganes. Ja siis seal oli näide John Smith. Iga
Õpetaja: Jah, mis? Ee Haruville varik tegi. Oih, perekonimi Tuli ka välja.
Õpetaja: Üleval Ikka oli ka. Siis ma mõtlesin. Omging Abia long right.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee. Teame selle haru Ära midagi siin otseselt praegu tegema. Ei pea. Aga vähemalt see seis on meil ee olemas. Kui te praegu tulete, vaatate oma seda Frontei Fronti lehte, siis ta peaks nägema välja umbes Midagi sellist,
Õpetaja: Midagi analoogset.
Õpetaja: Aga see. Selleks me veel tegeleme. Kui mingi jama on, siis,
Õpetaja: ee. Tahan hoopis hakata nüüd rääkima asjadest ja räägin asjadest.
Õpetaja: Siis teil on ka valid klassiruumis valid teemade järgi ja ma valin Fm neli
Õpetaja: ülevaade balsamikust. Me projekti juba vaatasime. Siis. Ee,
Õpetaja: ma ütlesin korra nüüd pildiseeriaid.
Õpetaja: Number.
Õpetaja: Oo, vana, Hea Kohvimassin ka.
Õpetaja: On kõigepealt
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah.
Õpetaja: Panen ühe video teile veel, sinna. Ee, tänaseks juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee, et sa vaataksid tegelikult ka selle ära. Et Me ei hakkagi seda jääpima. Seda on lihtsam vaadata
Õpetaja: Ee, kus oli See Tähtsamad teemad siin Selle video. Paneme ka juurde.
Õpetaja: Vaid nagu niimoodi on. Siin
Õpetaja: Mul ei tule meelde. Kas ma panin üldse selle lingi ikka sinna Ritale panin või ei pannud.
Õpetaja: Läks meelest Ikkagi, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma panen teile ühe. Ma panen selle restorani video siia juurde. Seda vaadak Saate vaadata ka? Ma ei viitsi seda praegu siin klassiruumis seda aega põletada. Vaatan, vajan abi.
Õpetaja: Võtan selle lehe.
Õpetaja: Mm, kus siin on see Share Link. Ma üldse ei näe praegult.
Õpetaja: Kas on sellel ühe share Link siin, vä?
Õpetaja: Ah jah, jah. Animaite link.
Õpetaja: Panen juba editoriks selle ära, et saab ka editada. Loodan, et keegi päris jama ei tee, et ära kustutab. Nii. Copy link, Ma panen selle ka ritale,
Õpetaja: nii Ee, ee, nii. Panen selle. Sinna. Ee, kui teil on küsimusi, siis küsib
Õpetaja: nii. See asi on ka ära tehtud. Ära Klaaritud Ee, siis tulen tagasi.
Õpetaja: Kõige Esimene asi, mis ma tahan teile rääkida on. Ee,
Õpetaja: vae, vae. Kus kohas on see asi Jah,
Õpetaja: Nii meil on nüüd Kaheksakümmend neli pilti vaja ära vaadata. Let s go.
Õpetaja: Kas Screenshare on üldse? Ma ilmselt küll oleks ammu juba öelnud, et mida siia äpid?
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt käsi.
Õpetaja: Jah, et kujutage ette.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kujutage ette, et teil on kaks siukest. Raamatut. On üks siukene raamat, mis on täis lehekülgi ja Siis on üks selline raamat. Kus siis on käind üks leht, mis on keskelt kokku murtud. Niiöelda üks leht. Ütleme,
Õpetaja: kas te olete kuulnud kunagi niukest asja nagu Single Page Application.
Õpetaja: Kui mina seda esimest korda nägin, siis mina mõtlesin, et see on üks nende single page Wapplication, Ma ütlesin, et see on see, kus sa lihtsalt Scroll Id alla. Ja nagu ma ei, ta näita mingi üldise info ära. Vaata
Õpetaja: Mm Its. Not that.
Õpetaja: Võin öelda kohe
Õpetaja: mis asi on Single Page application. Sest et Voe seda toetab. Ja eelkõige see ongi mõeldud Sellisena siis Räägime, mis? Ta on
Õpetaja: multiple Pages. Meil on Niukene raamat. Kus on palju lehti.
Õpetaja: See on siis selline süsteem, kus on väga palju Html Ee lehti eraldi. Html lehed.
Õpetaja: Võibolla siis korraks. Ee, laseme selle akna alla. Ta on kohe lahti. Jällegi No affiliation. Ei saa kuskilt Mingeid soodustusi ega midagi. Aga Booking dot com.
Õpetaja: Noh, otsime siis Ee. Tallinnast midagi.
Õpetaja: Noh, Search Search, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Noh, ühest ära ei tohigi, nagu Ei, pea,
Õpetaja: Võtame Hilton. Jällegi. No ma olen käinud. On päris okei.
Õpetaja: Kui ee praegult vaataksite Urli, Me pole väga urlidest rääkinud, millest koosneb Url,
Õpetaja: kui me hakkame siit ülevalt pihta, ma. Kas seda kuidagi suumida ei saa?
Õpetaja: Kõik see osa, mis ee on, kui on küsimärk juhul Kui on küsimärk, kõik see osa, mis on, ee, kuni küsimärgini on siis tegelik niiöelda aadress.
Õpetaja: See, mis tuleb peale seda küsimärki, on parameetrid, Sisendid Tallinn. Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Ee, paneme mingi kuupäeva ka. Siis On siin midagi paremat veel juures. Ütleme Check in Ee, niimoodi. Checkout search. Aga Vaatame korra. Mis siin urliga juhtub?
Õpetaja: Tallinn, Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Lähme siit edasi ja lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Check in. Näete, on see sama kuupäev, mis mul on alt valitud.
Õpetaja: Need on sisendid, Aga see ei ole osa selles mõttes sellest rajast, mis viitab konkreetsele lehele.
Õpetaja: Kas te olete kunagi teinud seda? Vaata, et Te otsite mingi koha välja ja siis tuleb välja, et Economy Hotell võiks olla võitja,
Õpetaja: onju?
Õpetaja: Ja siis on nagu. See, et te Tahate seda jagada nagu mingisugusele sõbrale, et. Kuule, kas lähme sinna või läheme Donna
Õpetaja: Ja siis te olete teinud. Seda läbi Näiteks Facebooki,
Õpetaja: kui Te panete selle Facebooki Noh, ma ei tea, kas ma julgen Facebooki lahti teha. Ee, teeme korra lahti.
Õpetaja: Ikka hüppavad siin mingid metsad siit lahti Kohe niikuinii. Proovime hästi ruttu nuppu vajutada, et seda juhtuks
Õpetaja: Nii naine ka siin.
Õpetaja: Kus ma saan vestluse iseendaga teete seda
Õpetaja: kuskil on infot vaja panna ja jagada telefoni arvuti. Vahelt ju pildid nagu halva kvaliteediga. Näete, millega mina olen tegelenud? Siin aiamaja ehitusega. Nii ma panen Control veel. Vaata Panete kuskile. Chat i gruppi. Vaata, et mis te sellest hotellist arvate. Ja siis tuleb plörake, et see Url on umbes Niuke, olete teinud seda?
Õpetaja: No tegelikult. Kui nüüd seda asja natukene niiöelda teistsuguse pilguga vaadata, siis Url ise
Õpetaja: on Alates siit algusest, kuni küsimärgini, mõistsid.
Õpetaja: Selle sama ee asukoha urli.
Õpetaja: Oleks saanud väga edukalt ka jagada niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nad. Viivad mõlema ühte samasse kohta kui. Ma teen selle lahti Siis Ta viib sinna Kohta
Õpetaja: Küll ei ole siin paigas tingimata. Ma olen praegu samas arvutis. Vaata, et tal on kuupäevad ja asjad meeles, Mitu tants onju?
Õpetaja: Kas tuli see sama Economy hotell lahti Tuli Ta ei ole mitte selles, kui vaadata seda teist, mis on see pikk onju. Ee, Kus Economy oli? Teen selle lahti. See on täpselt sama vaade. Noh, võibolla Economy Hotell Economy hotell. Oota
Õpetaja: nende kahe vahel. Lühike Pikk, lühike pikk on nii,
Õpetaja: siis ta tegelikult selle niiöelda selle lehe niiöelda Url on siin üleval. Ülejäänud on sisendi,
Õpetaja: et kui sa annad selle urli põhimõtteliselt. Ee, selle koleda asja annad siis? Seal on need kuupäevad ja tootused juba paigas. Noh, kas teistel on samad lapsed või mitte. Vaata, noh, polegi vaja. Vaata, et võibolla on teised. Aga point on see, et tegelt neid urle saad otsida, et mis see päris Urle on.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd seda urli vaatame, siis võiks ee, jääda silma. Üks väga eriline asi, punkt Html,
Õpetaja: Kui mina otsustan hoopis, et Ma soovin, noh, polegi vajutada kuhugi. Vajutan ka Research uuesti,
Õpetaja: et kui mina otsustan, et mina tahan hoopis Economy hoteli asemel vaadata Cityboksi
Õpetaja: Ah, Ah City Boks.
Õpetaja: Siis me näeme, et ühe hot ühe niiöelda lehekülje lõpus on Ee Citybox teisel.
Õpetaja: Kustutan selle vahelt ära. Võtame selle.
Õpetaja: Üks on economy bla, bla, bla blabla. Punkt. Html on nii?
Õpetaja: Sellel cityboksil on Cityboks. Tallinn, English Gb, Html.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd selline niiöelda server, Mis on Niukene? Klassikaline? Ee, selles mõttes veebiserver.
Õpetaja: Kus on palju Html Faile on mitmeid Html faile.
Õpetaja: Näeme isegi seda aadressi realti. Vaatame veel. See, vaata, on veel too ja. Ja nii edasi tulles nüüd selle pildiseeria juurde. Tagasi Meil on veebilehed, kus meil on, ee, veebiserverid, serverid,
Õpetaja: Kus on multiple htmel?
Õpetaja: Meil oli indeks. Saate Me mäletan, et mingi hetk tegime juurde tingimuse Html.
Õpetaja: Noh, otsime üles,
Õpetaja: tegime niimoodi, et meil oli indeks Atml ja seal oli link. Kui nõustud kõikide tingimustega, siis viis sellele lehele oli nii.
Õpetaja: See on kaks Htm meili.
Õpetaja: Nüüd need on niuksed klassikud. Aga mis on nagu siis Single Page Application
Õpetaja: on niimoodi, kus tegelikult, kogu projekti peale on ainult üks ja see sama Indeks, Atml, fail ja rohkem indeks Atml Faile. Pole?
Õpetaja: Või Noh, teisi Atml faile. Ei, Ole seal. Seda Economy ei ole seal see City Mis iganes vaid ongi ainult indeksi Atml. See on nagu, ee, Df, onju, et nagu mismoodi et. Aga me ju käime erinevatel lehtedel, et
Õpetaja: Mis alles tähendab natuke mõte on see, et see üks leht on väga eriline.
Õpetaja: Ta koostneb mitmest osast Nii nagu see väikene raamat, seal Meil on kaaned.
Õpetaja: Ee, värv on oranž ja meil on mingisugune sisu, mis on sinine, Nii,
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: ja veel. Kui edasi minna, siis meil selle sinu sisu. Selles. Mõtleme nüüd seda single. Page Application It. Kohe Niukse võluraamatuna.
Õpetaja: Meil on Niukene raamat. Põhimõtteliselt mis meile annab täpselt sellise Sisu, nagu meie soovime näha nagu veebilehti. Ta on kinokavad.
Õpetaja: Ütleme niimoodi, et kui mina ütlen, et mina tahaks näha informatsiooni ee, põldude ja Kuuskede kohta, siis
Õpetaja: maagiliselt ilmub üks uus vaade leht ja seal on mingi sisu.
Õpetaja: Nagu näiteks siin on, on mingi pilt ja mingeid asju,
Õpetaja: Kui mina, nagu ütleks, et ei mina tahan hoopis näha kõike, mis on, ee, teada meie päikese kohta, siis tuleb mingi niukene sisu.
Õpetaja: Meil On üks leht, mis kogu aeg muutub. Ja siin sees on niuke Content, mis on punasega markeeritud. Kui ma ütlen, et anna mulle sisu Kõikide põldude päikes, põldude kuuskede ja päikse kohta.
Õpetaja: Siis kombineeritavalt saab taaskasutada neid samu asju, mis me siin ennem nägime, sest et need on Content.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on ainult üks. Lähme
Õpetaja: meie infosüsteem. Vaadake video ka veel uuesti. Ära tegelikult sai
Õpetaja: uuesti. Vaadake siin video ära. Panin talle Slaki esimeseks sinna onju?
Õpetaja: See sama vana klassikaline näide. Midagi ma vist infotunnis Käisin selle läbi või ei käinud? Ma ei mäleta enam
Õpetaja: midagi, vist käisin, onju? Mingil kujul, et meil on siis klient.
Õpetaja: Klient nagu restoranis. Aga meil ei ole Nüüd nagu klient.
Õpetaja: Kurat, mul on ikkagi Niuke, tunne, et ma teen selle ruttu läbile selle seeria front and kui restoran
Õpetaja: meil on. Klient, istub lauas.
Õpetaja: Meil on vastuvõtt
Õpetaja: Vastuvõtust tuleb Serveerija annab meile menüü Menüü. Peal on Niukene päevakomba valikud, Supp Burger magustoit. Kolm erinevat varianti.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin ee erinevad variandid. Meie klient, Kes istub lauas, mõtleb, et tema valiks valiku ühe.
Õpetaja: Tema ütleb ei. Vastuvõtt Vaata vastuvõtt.
Õpetaja: Too mulle valik üks. Ehk siis too mulle See Kreemjas kõrvitsasub klassikaline veiseliha Burger tiramiisu
Õpetaja: meie restoran. Saab Selle sõnumi kätte tema ise sellega toimetama Ei, hakka. Vaid Tema võtab ühendust tagaruumiga,
Õpetaja: Aga Enne kui ta seda teeb? Siis Ta juba teab ette, et meil on tegelikult chef kokku pannud. Niisuguse kombo menüüd. Erinevad menüüd. Kust iga Päev Siis valitakse kolm toitu välja
Õpetaja: menüüsse.
Õpetaja: Meil on konkreetselt kreemjas kõrvitsasupp. Klassikaline veisiliha burger tiiramiisu, mida kui kasutajale näidati valik üks aga tegelikult Meie kelnerpoiss teab, et see on meil kombo viis.
Õpetaja: Nad on siin kreemias. Kõrvitsa supp. Klassikaline veisilihaburger. Tiira nisu on nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, ta siis Võtab tagaruumiga ühendust, et. Jou, jou, too kombo viis.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siin Esimene Asi on tähtis. Vaata, et tegelikult see klient ei tea sellest Kombo Viiest Mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Teda ei huvita see. Vaata, ta ei tea üldse. Tema lihtsalt tahab, et toit lauale seda tahab,
Õpetaja: aga meie vastuvõtt Meie tema teab, mida temal on vaja
Õpetaja: ja tema võib siis hakata asju paluma tagaruumil Sellepärast ega ta ise ei lähe nagu seda asja meisterdama. Igal ühel on oma ülesanne.
Õpetaja: Serveerija Ülesanne ongi väga lihtne esitlus Ehk serveerimine. Pane asjad lauale
Õpetaja: ja tema lõpuks, siis saab kätte oma mingi mandi ja annab selle tagasi lauda.
Õpetaja: Nii, need värvid on siin. Ka. Hästi, natukene. Meil on siin sinine värv.
Õpetaja: Ee, tuleb neid vär Värve veel. Lõppkokkuvõttes tuleb umbes mingi niukene joonis välja. Kus meil on? Ee, server. Vabandust, Client läpakas. Browser, server backend andmebaas.
Õpetaja: Nii, paneme selle kinni. Ja Nüüd läheme tagasi selle võlu raamatu juurde, mille ma jõudsin ka juba kinni panna. Ja
Õpetaja: meil on selline Magical Book. Kujutage ette Põhimõtteliselt mida iganes, see, et. Aga seal on ainult üks leht sees. Aga ta dünaamiliselt muutub vastavalt sellele mida vaja. Meil on Client
Õpetaja: Client I sees on brauser. See on päris client. See on nagu nende. Sellistes diagrammides on ta klient Client alati niukse terminoloogia
Õpetaja: niukest vaadet ja temal on siis Vahet pole kas ta klikkis mingeid nuppu vajutas kuskile linki või ise trükkis selle sisse. Kui Sa liigute, vajutate nuppu ja Browser viib teid kuskile teisele leheküljel. Siis aadress rida. Siin üleval muutub.
Õpetaja: See ongi see, et anna mulle see lehekülg. Vaata, See on kogu Url.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see osa siin. Enne seda esimest Kaldkriipsu Locations. Vaata, on serveri aadress adressaat vastu võtta.
Õpetaja: See Siin on, mida ma tahan.
Õpetaja: Too valik. Üks vahet on see, et anna mulle veebileht. Locations, Palun
Õpetaja: Kogu see asi tervikuna. Kui see asi ära renderdab, siis meie näites tekitaks Sihukese lehekülje. Meil on siin mingi menüü üleval. Meil on siin mingisugune header Atm Location. Meil on mingi tabel siin andmetega Atm Location inglise Keeles, onju?
Õpetaja: City Location Transaction types Tallinn Market Cash in cash out payments cash in cash out.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Kuidas See vaade tuleb Single Page Applications on niimoodi, et tegelikult
Õpetaja: meil taustal. Me saame ainult selle ühe ja selle sama indeks. Html Faili
Õpetaja: See Html, mis tuleb Brauserile üle anda.
Õpetaja: Aga tema nüüd failide mõttes
Õpetaja: hakkab nagu dünaamiliselt koosnema. Mitmest erinevast osast, näiteks. Noh, siin See näide on natukene lihtsustatud et juba selle Indeks Html I Sees on olemas. See
Õpetaja: ee niiöelda üleval riba menüü.
Õpetaja: Siis vastavalt sellele rajale, mis siin on, Locations, aktiveerub järgmine asi, et Hei,
Õpetaja: osa. No ma korra panen tagasi. Näete, kogu see osa lihtsalt tuleb mitmest erinevast failist,
Õpetaja: sest Locations Views on siis põhimõtteliselt ee, ära Defineeritud, et mida ma tahan, sellest vaatest endast tuleb Võibolla ainult see heeder tabel, aga mõtleme ilma sisuta. Tegelt isegi ei tule Seda tuleb Kõik põhimõtteliselt siin. Selles näituses ongi kõik. Tuleb ainult see heeder.
Õpetaja: See tuleb sellest vaatest. Aga seal on niimoodi programmeeritud, et mul on vaja Selles vaates näidata mingeid asju. Ma tahan kasutada mingit klotsi, mida ma saan taaskasutada
Õpetaja: igal pool, kui tahaks Näiteks See sisu tuleb mujalt failist. Meil on indeks Atml,
Õpetaja: mis tuleb niikuinii. Ainult Siis üks Atm. Meil ongi,
Õpetaja: Aga tema osa tema sisust tuleb vastavalt sellele rajale, kuhu kasutaja tahab minna.
Õpetaja: See osa täpselt samamoodi nagu see Magic Bock. Meil on kaaned, mis on niikuinii
Õpetaja: See on, Meil eks? Saate veel, fail
Õpetaja: Meil on sinine osa, mis defineerib ära. Mida kuradit sa üldse näha tahad?
Õpetaja: Ja meil on content,
Õpetaja: mis võib olla ka eraldi failides eraldi klotsides Selles mõttes, et ka me ei soovi, et meil kõik kogu staff oleks ühes. Vaatame veel failis
Õpetaja: või lihtsalt paljudes või lihtsalt ei oleks Pikad failid.
Õpetaja: Okei. Lähme edasi. Kas jaksate? Vaatame pildid ära? Võibolla sööme teha pausi. Ma näen, mõned on veits väsinud. Juba
Õpetaja: ei imesta, nii et hakkab siis pihta, et kõigepealt, ee, serveri aadress laeb ainult ühe Html Faili
Õpetaja: Pole vahet, Apollo Kino punkt e nagu vahetaks üks Atml Fail.
Õpetaja: Meil ongi projektis üks indeks. Atml fail. See on see osa siin.
Õpetaja: Kogu see osa, mis on siin Bodys põhimõtteliselt on nähtav osa
Õpetaja: Ja me näeme, et siin on üleval. Ee, menüü, Home Atm Slow out.
Õpetaja: See on siin juba olemas.
Õpetaja: See on see sama menüü siin üleval,
Õpetaja: Sest et see on osa sellest indeks. Htm Failist. Nii lähme edasi. Aga nüüd on sinine osa. Näed, siin kood saab otsa. Mäletate, Kui pikk oli meie Html fail
Õpetaja: oma üheksakümnendates stiilis panga. No oli juba Mitu kilomeetrit on ju siin? Kood saab otsa
Õpetaja: selles failis aga Siin öeldakse, et
Õpetaja: väike kommentaar on juures, viidatakse siin mingi Id äp ile.
Õpetaja: Mm, mis teema on?
Õpetaja: See osa on olemas, aga mingi osa Nüüd tuleb vastavalt rajale
Õpetaja: See osa siin. Tegelikult on see osa, mis on nüüd taustal ära programmeeritud, et vastavalt vaatele kuvatakse. No, siin on Väiksed nüansid veel. Vaata aga me võibolla neid väga. Vaata, nüüd ongi see. Öeldakse, et vastavalt vaatele tuleb ülejäänud Html I osa tuleb Locations View Failist
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil see näide Locations View nii öelda failist.
Õpetaja: Siin on niuksed targid nagu template
Õpetaja: templeid. Template algab. Template lõpeb nüüd Kogu see osa, mis jääb selle template vahele, on nüüd järgmine osa Html. Ist,
Õpetaja: mis läheb sinna lõpptulemusse, et kujutage ette. Võtke praegu. Nagu Kujutage ette, et see kood Nii,
Õpetaja: võtad selle kaasa. Lähed tagasi siia Kohta on selle sinise koodi asemel. Siin on Html. Html, Html, Html, Html Siin on jätkuvalt. Html. Html. Html. Aga lihtsalt. Mis iganes on, siin on nii.
Õpetaja: Siit tuleb header. Atm Locations, H. Üks Oleme tuttavad, Onju? Täpselt nagu seal pildil oli.
Õpetaja: See on veel kõik siit failist. Aga siit omakorda kutsutakse välja. Vaata, see kogu see, kogu see vaa See fail laetakse vaate peale, Aga nüüd oleme programmeerinud, et Kuule, Locations. Tabel on eraldi fail ja me sellele lihtsalt siin niimoodi viitame ja Ülejäänud Html. Nüüd tuleb sellest failist.
Õpetaja: Läheme edasi.
Õpetaja: Siit on see siin. On see. Niiöelda see, aga ülejäänud osa tuleb järgmisest failist.
Õpetaja: Me läheme edasi. Siin on nüüd näide Locations Ee, tabelist. Kõik, mis on template osas, on nähtav osa meie rakendusest. Siin on Table City Location Transaction Types table. Mida iganes, see on, savivad. See on päris koodinäidis.
Õpetaja: Siin on Html i palju.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kujutame jälle. Me läheme sammud ette, Vaata, et meil oli osa. Meil on osa, mis Html Ist tuleb siit
Õpetaja: osa, mis tuli siit. Ja see tegelikult ka enda. Nüüd selle indeksi Atml. I mõttes on kõik siin. Ta on kõik koos.
Õpetaja: Ta pannakse kokku.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt. Dünaamiliselt tuleb sihuke pilt.
Õpetaja: Maagiline raamat. Meil on kaaned, mis tuleb niikuinii. Meil on sinine osa, et mis lehte sa tahad näha? Ja seal Lehel on see, et mis seal lehel siis võiks olla sisu.
Õpetaja: See ei ole kõik lihtsalt ühes failis, vaid see on jagatud lihtsalt erinevate failide peale ära.
Õpetaja: Ja see kind on nagu meil on Üks suur memm jälle. See on väiksem memm.
Õpetaja: Kelle sees on veel väiksem memm
Õpetaja: ja võib neid memmes ei ole seal mitmeid.
Õpetaja: Noh, see Nüüd hakkab otsast. Aa, okei, nüüd vaatame seda. Tehniliselt läheb sõnum teele.
Õpetaja: Mängib rolli. Esiteks, et kellele kuradile on see sõnum üldse mõeldud? See on serveri aadress. Apollo kinod, punkt. E, e
Õpetaja: põmm. Keegi kuskil maamunal on päris server. Vaata, kes ootab nagu sisse sõnumeid.
Õpetaja: Niipea Kui tuleb sõnum sisse, siis tema hakkab panema. Kokku. Html, lehekülge indeks. Html. See üksnes ainus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mängib rolli See Locations. Näete, mida sa tahad
Õpetaja: Nüüd on programmeeritud ära, et Locations View File peaks kuvama.
Õpetaja: Seal sees on ära defineeritud, et peaks olema Locations Table mida peaks kuvama jälle see Sama Raamat,
Õpetaja: sisu, kogu lehekülg.
Õpetaja: Siis on niimoodi. Et mis nüüd toimub, on see, et pannakse kokku niukene väikene kompott, nagu sees on Html Ja natuke nänni veel. See On see tehnoloogia, kuidas ta dünaamiliselt suudab uuendada. Ja nii edasi. Kohe räägin sellest dünaamilisusest ka.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt see antakse nüüd Browserile. Nüüd Browser is on olemas indeks. Html. Tal on kogu see Html i osa olemas.
Õpetaja: Tal on see nagu sellisel kujul on see Brauseris olemas. Aga loomulikult Brauser tahab seda nüüd Ee renderdada. Nagu mingisuguseks visuaalseks asjaks. Aga on üks probleem.
Õpetaja: Andmeid pole, pole andmeid
Õpetaja: nüüd, et neid andmeid saada siis Brauser peab veel nüüd eraldi hakkama. Neid andmeid ära tooma ja ta võib seda mitu korda teha. Ta võib Sada sõnumit ka teele panna. Kõik lähevad samaaegselt teele
Õpetaja: tagasi, Tulevad nagu tulevad. Ja siis ta hakkab iga vastuse puhul tegema seda, mis ta tegema peab, onju? Aga point on see, et andmed on puudu. Nüüd. Kas Browser otse läheb Backendi vastu või ta tegelikult mängib läbi nüüd Selle Frontend Browser I
Õpetaja: sõnum läheb Fronti ja Front saadab edasi. Kas on vahendaja või mitte on lihtsalt nagu siis konfitav teema? Vaata ja Arhitektuuriline küsimus.
Õpetaja: No Lõpptulemus on sama. Back end. Ile läheb. Sõnum on andmeid.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma panen selle
Õpetaja: kokku? Vaata, et ega see ei ole Frondi ülesanne. Frondi ülesanne on serveerida. Kelnerpoiss ei käinud ka ju mingi toitu valmistamas ja kandikule midagi panemas onju? Teised mehed on selle jaoks
Õpetaja: Siin mängib rolli see jällegi. Vaata, et sõnum läheb teele. Need on restsõnumid. See on arhitektuur ja tehnoloogia kandida Ee, et kuidas saab omavahel Süsteemid suhelda niukse päringutega.
Õpetaja: Need urlid ja asjad ongi teemal, et siis läheb sõnum. Aga seekord näete, ei lähe enam Dot Com Ile vaid läheb. Back Punkt Atms. Dot Com on Mingi teine. Server. Füüsiliselt. See võib olla tegelikult ühes samas arvutis, nagu meilgi on. Pole vahet, aga See sõnum kuulub kellelegi.
Õpetaja: See kõnd kulub konkreetsele Back and serverile.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd mängib siin rolli. Näete, mõlemad on siin Highlight Id Kenasti. Ära, et see sõnum. Mis läheb? See sõnum, mis tuleb Clientilt mis? Tuleb. Nagu sealt läpakast. Need on kaks erinevat sõnumit
Õpetaja: ja siin on nüüd vaja aru saada, et need nimed ja need rajad ei pea kuidagi kattuma.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et tegelikult Vaata, Frontile tuleb ainult üks sõnum aga Batile läheb? Võibolla ma ei tea mingi viis sõnumit, et saada kogu
Õpetaja: staff kätte. Näiteks et et siin ei saagi kattuda. Vaata ja. Ja see ongi, see, et need mõlemad urlid ja rajad peavad olema niimoodi, mis konkreetselt selles serveris kõnetavad ja on nagu kuidagi arusaadavad,
Õpetaja: need rajad ei Ole juhuslikud. Need me peame ise välja Mõtlema. On kindlad reeglid ja asjad. Vaata, mida peab jälgima. Aga me peame ise põhimõtteliselt nagu planeerima, Et mis teenused meil on ja kuidas meid see asi kõnetaks, kui siin on praegult Niukene asi, Gett Atm Location, siis see juba annab Viite põhimõtteliselt, mida me tahame. Me tahame saada andmeid.
Õpetaja: Vaatame Location Ite kohta mitmuses, mis peaks vastu tagasi tulema, on siis Jason File? Vaatasime Jasonit just ennem
Õpetaja: me inimene saab sellest aru. Arvuti saab aru. Selles kontekstis on mõlemal vajadus saada. Me programmeerime. Meil on vaja programmeerida nende sõnumite vastu. Ja päriselt, Siis Programm peab töötlema neid. Ee, niiöelda, nagu me programmeerime. Siin on näide.
Õpetaja: Siin on massiiv. Ee, jah, ühe asja Panen veel listi juurde Ka veel, kui list Ei, enda panekski. Võibolla. Ja ära ei pea maitset Staffi juurde panema.
Õpetaja: Meil on niukene asi, et meil on siin Niukene. Jason, kus Meil on? Kaks objekti. Mäletate objekt literaalina? Loogilised sulud.
Õpetaja: See siin see on. Kast. Näed, Kast algab. Kast lõpeb? On nii.
Õpetaja: Kasti. Sees on kaks objekti komaga on eraldatud. Siin see on üks objekt. Väga objekti sees on Location Id Cityname Location Name,
Õpetaja: et tallinn sikupilli. Ee, Market Location Id ühega.
Õpetaja: Siin on transaction types. Jällegi, see on võti väärtus. Tema on omakorda kastikene kasti Sees on kast. On ju
Õpetaja: kasti sees? On veel teine. Kastesi all on objektid. Nad on hästi lihtsustatud Siin Iga kasti sees on lihtsalt Väli Üks objekt. Transaction type name. Cash in Cash Out Payments.
Õpetaja: Noh, all on siis teine. Ee Tallinn Tondi supermarket. Siin on ainult siin on kolm. Siin on kaks arusaadav
Õpetaja: Location Stable. Nüüd Browser saab selle kätte. Näete, ta on siin
Õpetaja: ja nüüd Brauser. Vastavalt meie programmeerimisele teeb selle tabeli valmis.
Õpetaja: Põmm olemas kattuvad. Näed siin sikupilli? Supermarket.
Õpetaja: Cash in Cash Out Payments
Õpetaja: ja tondi supermarket. Ainult Cashing Cash Out taustal Tegelikult, Selle rea taga on olemas peidus ka Location Id.
Õpetaja: Seda lihtsalt me ise otsustame, mida näitame. Mida mitte. See on serveerija teema. Teema otsustab. Vaata, nagu mis. On nagu viisakas ja mis on vaja, mida ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga idee järgi meil on seda vaja, sest kui me Mingi järgmine samm on see Näiteks, et ole hea. Mine Editi seda. Location It. Kustuta see location ära,
Õpetaja: siis kuidas? Nagu see süsteemid omavahel suhtlevad. Ja kuidas andmebaasis asjad on? See, et nendel kõikidel asjadel on mingid omad Id D, mis viitavad andmetele.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole vaja teada sikupilli supermarket. Kui me tahame seda editima minna, Meil piisab sellest, kui me teame, mis on tema Id Location Id selle vastu, tahame järgmisel vaatajal toimetada.
Õpetaja: Või kui tahame teda näiteks kustutada,
Õpetaja: On teil küsimusi Multi versus Single Page Application, et, ee, Mis nende erinevus on,
Õpetaja: ehk et Singel on lihtsalt nii.
Õpetaja: Aeg on singel, on sing. Singel on uus.
Õpetaja: Mul küsitakse tihtipeale seda, et, ee, kas milline on kõige parem programmeerimiskeel Või Siis seda niiöelda suunatud küsimusega, et kas Java on kõige parem Keel
Õpetaja: Siis on nagu selle asjaga. Vaata, et nagu ük nagu, absoluutselt Iga asjaga on. See Vaata, absoluutselt, igal keeleraamistikul ja lähenemisel on omad plussid ja miinused
Õpetaja: on palju palju plusse ja mingisuguseid miinuseid ja kunagi ei ole niukest asja. Vaata, et, ee, Üks asi on parem kui teine. Võib muidugi seda olla, et mingi tehnolo Noh, näiteks Kobolit keegi enam väga ei kasuta. Paideway, nad on. Meie vennad. On jälle hinnas. Vaata,
Õpetaja: vanad pangandussüsteemid panevad mingi koboli peale. On ju et loomulikult seda Juhtub, et mingisugused asjad nagu kaovad nagu ajaloo unustuse hõlma, onju? Ja olen ka näitand. Mingisugused näited on ju? Aga siin ei ole üks nendest, et selles mõttes multipage ei ole kuhugi kadunud ja ei ole kuhugi veel kadumas.
Õpetaja: Tal on omad mingisugused plussid ja ma ütlen, et Ega booking Dot com. Ega nad ei ole vaene ettevõte. Ma pakuks. Ee, kui nad tahaksid, et vanast ajast on jäänud, see vaata, neil On piisavalt palju pappi, et uuesti ehitada. Kui nad tahaks,
Õpetaja: Neil ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Kus on vaja? Mis on üldse nagu selle, mis on Nagu selle Single Place Application I. Nagu peamine eelis. Ja miks ta üldse tekib,
Õpetaja: Kui andmed juhtuvad kogu aeg,
Õpetaja: kus muutuvad andmed nagu väga Kiirelt. Nagu. Ei, see ei ole see. Me ei räägi. Andmed muutuvad nagu stiilis andmebaas.
Õpetaja: Andmed muutuvad reaalajas, kui näpid. Ee, seda.
Õpetaja: Noh, näiteks Aktsiaturg Või jälle? On need Mkm?
Õpetaja: Kohe jõuame näiteni. Vaata, mis Nagu peaks. Nagu teile selle pähe paikale osutama.
Õpetaja: Kas keegi teab, ee, mis On need põhite kolm nagu tehnoloogiad? Nüüd seda raamistikku tänapäeval. No üks on Angular. Üks on voe. Üks on veel
Õpetaja: kõige tuntum ja kõige Populaarsem reakt. Mis tähendab üldse React? Vaata, reageeri. On ju React,
Õpetaja: kes töötas välja Täna on ta Open Open Source Facebook.
Õpetaja: Miks Facebookil järsku Oli vaja mingit reactive nagu välja disainida ja luua ja teha see tehnoloogia ja arendada,
Õpetaja: mis on Facebook? Il väga erilist
Õpetaja: Kui te lähete Facebooki sisse Kuhu te maandute? Live Feed i Wall Scroll Id alla. Mis juhtub, tuleb uus. Ahaa
Õpetaja: vaadake. Konks on selles, et. Ee, kui me korra praegult kasutame. Booking dot, com I. Ja siis me mõtleme selle nurga alt. Seda ma lähen korra. Booking Dot com ja vaatan, Kas te märkate midagi, kui ma. Ma lähen tagasi korra sellele otsimislehele.
Õpetaja: Kus sa siin oled,
Õpetaja: kui ma vajutan? Aa, praegult see u üksteist Hotell Spa. Mida iganes, kui ma korra vajutan, mis te märkate,
Õpetaja: laeb, Mis juhtus?
Õpetaja: Korraks tuli valg. Valge. Vaata, onju Kogu Html laeti uuesti, Ta läheb korra eest ära. Tuleb kogu sisuga uuesti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kujutage ette. Vaata kui see lõputu. Scroll, vaata, mis on. Vaata, mille vastu nüüd Juba hakkavad siin mingid valitsused ka veits võitlema. Vaata, on ju, et.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on lõputu. Scroll, vaata. See on nagu väga tiktiv seal Tulegi lõppu. Keegi pole kunagi jõudnud nagu Tiktoki lõppu, onju. Videod ära näinud Nagu ja uuele ringile ei lase. Vaata, see on
Õpetaja: Facebook On natuke teine teema. Sellepärast, et seal võib olla kellegi konkreetne vool ja mälestused. Ja et see algab mingist punktist, onju? Tiktok on veel parem Näide aga ikkagi. Mis te arvaksite sihukesteks peeneksist, et te ee, seal Facebookis allapoole. Vaata, onju. Ja niipea, kui lähed sinna alla, käib plõks Ekraan läheb valgeks.
Õpetaja: Ee, kõik kogu sisu laetakse uuesti ülesse.
Õpetaja: Scroll võibolla tirib sind ülesse. Nüüd saad natukene jälle allapoole. Scrollida ei töötaks. Vist Väga see kontseptsioon. See nagu ei oleks väga nauditav kogemus, kui Ta Refresh iks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see Single Page Application. Seda asja lahendabki,
Õpetaja: et nad Mõtlesid välja tehnoloogia lahenduse. Vaata, et kuidas me saame teha niimoodi, et. Ee, mitte. Me ei muuda nagu kasutaja brauseris. Ee, nagu, et ei Lae kogu lehte, uuesti, vaid ainult osa sellest laenu uuesti
Õpetaja: ei tule usutada. Selles mõttes. Noh, ma ütlen, visuaalises võib kõik olla nagu, et Teil võib igal pool. Ma ütlen. Nüüd ongi see, et kõik on ülipetlik. Vaata nende single. Page Application Itega on Niimoodi et teile või Teile jääb mulje, et mina liigun ühelt lehelt teisele.
Õpetaja: Jah te liigute ühelt vaatelt teisele. Aga tegelikult, selle html lehe mõttes, teil on ainult Üks Ja ainus Html fail, mis dünaamiliselt lihtsalt osade kaupa muutub. Mis sa sellega saavutad, on see. Vaata, et sa ei pea laadima kõiki andmeid. Ehk siis,
Õpetaja: kui sa Scroll Id sinna oled. Sa Facebook laeb ära. On ju mingi Atml Ja mingisugune osa on nähtav, on ju Kuidas see tehnoloogia taustal töötab? Ma. Ma ei tea seda hingeelu nii nii sügavalt. Ee, karukohust. Aga see on umbes niimoodi vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, tema Seal see frontend Nagu server. Nagu saab. Aru. Vaata, et. Ee. Vabandust, See Brauser saab nagu aru, Vaata, mida tal nagu järgmiseks vaja.
Õpetaja: See Tehnoloogia on ka kuidagi niimoodi siis tehtud. Vaata, et ta ei lähe nüüd tooma ära. Nagu kuidagi tervet. Seda kogu see asi nagu rajaneb andmete peale see loksub paika. Ta ei ole nüüd siin järgnevate päevade jooksul. Või nii, et ta põhimõtteliselt lõpptulemusena mõte on see, et ainult Osaliselt see
Õpetaja: brauseris. See Html I. Niiöelda kood. Seal muutub ainult osaliselt.
Õpetaja: Ainult see väike osa laetakse juurde. Ülejäänud osa on kõik alles ja juba olemas. Ehk siis sealt tulebki see reaktiivsus. Vaata
Õpetaja: see on. See on nagu progemise küsimus, et kas taustad on olemas pigem jaa,
Õpetaja: et Selles mõttes, et sa. Et sul ei tekiks nagu päriselt Seda, et korraks laev juurde jääd seisma. Jah, sest et ma mõtlen, et ma ütlen. Nüüd. On Kõik on ülimalt petlik. Vaata, et, ee. See, mis sa nagu näed ja mis seal tegelikult taustal juba olemas on võivad olla nagu väga erinevad. Vaata, ja kui sulle tundub, et sina läksid ühelt lehelt teisele, siis sa tegelikult ei ole kuhugi otseselt. Noh, sa Sa oled nagu läinud nagu. Aga. Aga mitte nagu selle.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: tehnilises mõttes. Sa ei lähe teise, Sa ei lähe nagu teise, sa ei lähe. Ei laeta. Tingimused, punkt Html
Õpetaja: vaid Lihtsalt see keskmine osa lihtsalt muutub kogu kupatusega ära.
Õpetaja: Jah, see on päris äge. See on äge Tehnoloogia. See tegelikult on. Ee, väga hea, aga loomulikult multipage ei ole läinud. Ka Voe toetab seda, et saab olla palju Html faili. See Ei ole üldse nagu
Õpetaja: kuidagi keelatud. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga ütleme niimoodi, et. Ee, Väga Väga paljud asjad ikka. Pigem nagu lähevad täna nagu selle teed pidi. Vaata sellepärast, et seal on igasuguseid plusse. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Näiteks auto. Kakskümmend neli. Minu meelest. Minu meelest seal on ka veebilehed. Me pole vaadanud. On tegelikult väga palju nagu kohti. Vaata, kus on nagu igatepidi Fine, vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: et ee. On eraldi. Tehakse seda dünaamilist hinnastust, ka et kui
Õpetaja: tellitakse taksot Ee Apple St. Eksole, siis on see Hind On üks. Tellitakse sama lehe pealt teisest.
Õpetaja: No loomulikult Ega siin on mingid regioonid ja asjad, et vana vana trikk. Vaata Sky Scanneriga otsida mingit lennukipileteid, et läksid mingi kaudu. On õed, hinnad, Lähed mingi India oma kaudu? On rupjates plekid, Aga muidu hinnad on paremad. Vaata, numbrid on suuremad.
Õpetaja: Hind on parem Okei.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma arvan, et äkki. Kas me oleme vist enamvähem nüüd jälle poolteist tundi töötanud? Et äkki nüüd teeme väikese pausi
Õpetaja: ja siis ee, Vaatame edasi
Õpetaja: järgmisena. Vaatame või? Okei, viimane asi. Tegelikult oled veel mõttelaine. See on ainult viis pilti.
Õpetaja: Sa nägid siin on selles mõttes ee, vananenud selles mõttes, Et, ee. Vanasti. Kui tegid uue poeprojekti, siis ta nägi välja vaikimise. Niimoodi siuke näidis oli kohe kaasas
Õpetaja: see sama lehekülg. Tegelikult, Ee, on Siis Siin Dave Toolsiga lahti võetud. Kogu lehekülje sisu, mida siin näha, on, on see üks sama fail
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd hakkabki tulema, et ee, Kõigepealt tuleb mingi osa indeks Atml ist. Siis tuleb nihukesest failist nagu upvoe. See tuleb selle Id järgi. Siis tuleb vastavalt vaatele ja siis Tuleb üks näidiskomponent, mis on kõik see sama osa. Ehk saate, aru, et see see on nüüd, mis Browser Is on?
Õpetaja: Browser is on Tegelikult see üks indeks. Atml.
Õpetaja: Need hallid. Vabandust, need oranžid. Osad siin. Tegelikult mitte kunagi kvoodi mõttes ei muutu. Alates sellest vaatest hakkavad asjad dünaamiliselt muutuma.
Õpetaja: Niipea kui keegi läheb ühelt rajalt teisele.
Õpetaja: Okei, ühesõnaga, ee, teeme siinkohal siis pausi. Ma jätan selle siia niisama ette ee rekordimises ka pausi.
Õpetaja: Teeme siis viisteist pizza ja siis on päeva viimane.
Õpetaja: Ee Davaika. Davaika Davaika. Ee, Proovime siis olla nüüd nüüd õhtuti. Mul kipub See tempo. Teie tahate olla siin väsinud ja haigutate. Mina tahan tempot juurde krüptida, et jõuaks võimalikult palju enne homselt midagi veel õppida. Davai Ee, tehke projekt lahti. Feb nelja. Võtsite juba lahti, On ju ka?
Õpetaja: Ee, selle haru tegite.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina nüüd lähen. Ee, päriselt. Lähen korra siis siirasse. Hästi, natuke palju lehti on lahti. Ma võibolla tõmban selle asja natukene
Õpetaja: kokku.
Õpetaja: Ee, teen lahti. Ee, siis. Aga ma teen ta eraldi lahti, et ka kuhugi taustale, Kui vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, otsin siit üles. Ee, siis Chira projekti. Frontend Pank.
Õpetaja: Aa, see on kusjuures. Ta oli Esimene grupp, kellel on mugavalt see niimoodi nähtav ka Vanasti oli mul ühes teises teise konto peal. Mis kustus ära?
Õpetaja: Ee, Kui kaks kuud sisse ei logi, Siis nagu atlasjana, on savi kustutada kõik selle ära. Enne seda kursust mul oli haige tehtud, päris palju asju, kõik need Taaskid, mis? Ma olin aastate jooksul teinud ja timminud ära. Oli
Õpetaja: Ee, ma jagan võibolla ühe lingi ka siis praegult siia alla, et saate kiiremalt niimoodi tulla. Siia, Samma. Siin on siis kõik taaskid.
Õpetaja: Meie hakkame neid järjest võtma. Siin on üleval timeline kus on nagu neid niimoodi kenasti näha, aga me üldiselt läheme hoopis spordi järgi.
Õpetaja: Board on siin ka. Niukene valik, kus Nad on nagu enamvähem õiges järjekorras,
Õpetaja: ee, sest Et tingimata ei pea neid tegema. Siin Ma pean ka veits veidi tõstma, aga see feb. Neli on päeva lõpuks. Mis te soovite vaadata Kui Te laski numbrile niiöelda vajutate, tuleb Niukene visual lahti. Kui siin üleval ühe korra veel vajutad, siis, ta nagu teeb kogu lehe ulatuses Selline on parim vaade. Noh, kogu lehe ulatuses on näha.
Õpetaja: Ee, on nagu näeb. Öeldakse, et muuda kodu Vaadet Ee muuda ee koduvaate komponent Home You all järgnevaks navigatsiooni menüüsse peaks jääma link kodu
Õpetaja: Võibolla lihtsalt teksti või ikooni kujul. No teeme teksti kujul. Ee, võiks selle veel Kuvada Mingid teksti. See on meie äge pank ja mingi pilt või Gif või mis iganes
Õpetaja: kustutaja. Ebavajalikud asjad. Kui te teete uue projekti, Siis seal on Mingi kama. On kohe kaasas Näitena, Vaata, ma olen juba niikuinii ära pookinud ja teinud veits ümber, onju Mingid, asjad on siin tehtud. Aga suures pildis.
Õpetaja: Kasuta router indeks. Cs is nimeosas konventsiooni Homerood.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd, mis puudutab taaski lugemisse. Siis Ee, kui te päris elust loete taaski, siis te tegelikult võtate taaski ette ja tasub seda. Tegelikult mingi. Vähemalt kaks, kolm korda täiesti Rahulikult. Niimoodi kõva häälega ära lugeda, üritada, aru saada, et mis on vaja ja siis hakata nagu Jupiti nagu tulema. Vaata, mis nüüd siis tegema peab. Vaata, on ju.
Õpetaja: No Mida keerukam on on taas, seda,
Õpetaja: Ee, seda rohkem on siis võibolla seda lugemist.
Õpetaja: Ee, hästi, kiirelt räägin. Proovin seda lühikesena hoida. Mul oli viimane Lhv taast, mis mul oli. Osalesin ühes projektis, kus me tahtsime teha. See on Niukene teenus. Nagu direct debit otsekorraldus. Aga nagu Sellisel viisil, kus, ee, niiöelda teenusepakkuja ise seab ülesse omavahelise niiöelda otsekorraldussuhte. Ja sina, nagu lihtsalt selle accept, I
Õpetaja: et mitte niimoodi, et sa Nagu lähed, mingi online panka ja ütled, et näe, iga kuu läheb mul raha sinna vaid, et see teenus tuleb nagu teistpidi sisse mingi Rahvusvaheline süsteem ja Lhv tahtis teha ka liidestust, mida tahtis, vaid tegi, Ka Tahtis teha siis liidestuse ühe teise välise süsteemiga, ja mis tegi Sealt selle asja keerukaks oli see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, panganduses on põhimõtteliselt raha, mis tuleb. Sisse. Vaata, on ju seal nagu teised, nagu õiged Terminoloogiad kõrval on debit ja Kreedit. Debit on papp. Välja. Kredit on papp. Ee, vabandust, no hea. Kui ma pidin nüüd meelest ära,
Õpetaja: Ee, Kreedit panga mõttes ja Transaction is on ikkagi raha sisse
Õpetaja: Ja debitan raha välja kuidagi nii. Ee, me siis kindlustasime ühe süsteemiga ja siis oli niimoodi, et kaks süsteemi hakkavad omavahel suhtlema. Seal oli kohut tohutu virvar Vaata, et Ee, Mis hetkel mingisugused konkreetselt kellaajal ööpäevas, oli et Hakkab midagi toimuma. Mingid protsessid ja meie. See süsteem pidi seal midagi tegema Ja nende süsteemi. Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Mis sa tegid veel eriti rõvedaks asja. Loo on see, et meil meie süsteemis Kredit ja Deed läksid omavahel nagu tagurpidi. Vaata, et et nende süsteemi kirjandus olid ühtepidi Aga meil oli ta teistpidi, et sa pidid kuidagi tavapäratult, nagu ka neid asju nagu tagurpidi mõtlema. Aga peamine mure oli see, et see oli mingi väga, väga spetsiifiline käitumismudel.
Õpetaja: Kuidas seal mingisugusel hetkel mingid protsessid teevad ja toimetavad. Ja kuhu lähevad andmed ja kust tulevad ja mis peab toimuma. See oli täielik. Meil oli Niukene väikene team. Siis pandud kokku kes seda projekti niiöelda Üks vanema arendaja, kaks minutit me level Venda poole pealt ka mingi tüübid, analüütik,
Õpetaja: ee. Ja midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Ja see oli tegelikult väga rets projekt. Selles mõttes et mul just oli Nädalas vist oli lausa Lhv S. Oli üldiselt niisugune kultuur, et miitingud oli. Toitakse miinimumini, eriti arendajad. Arendajad Niisama. Ei topinudki, kuskile miitingule, vaata, Kui Just ei ole vaja. Mis oli väga tervitatav nagu kultuur. Sellepärast, et arendaja tahab vist arendada, mitte käia. Miitingutel Onju
Õpetaja: aga seal me Olime nagu sundseisus. Sellepärast, et see projekt oli paran paganama keerukas. Ja mina siis sain ka mingisugused taaskid seal mingi kolm tükki, üks arendaja Sai veel nad kuidagi veel omavahel. Mängisid kokku
Õpetaja: ja minu, ee, päev siis konkreetselt ühe. Taskeri raames, mis ma kõige rohkem nagu tegin ei olnud seal mingisugune nädalane asi. Seal sai ikka päris rõvedalt. Sai vahepeal nähtud.
Õpetaja: Mu päev Algas. Niimoodi, et ma ärkasin ülesse. Ma tegin kodukontorit Sel ajal ma ärkasin ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin endale kohvi. Ma läksin just taha maha. Ja mis ma tegin? Ma tegin taski lahti, siis ma Hakkasin seda taaski lugema. Mis? Sest, et ma olin seda taaski tegelikult ilma naljata juba sada korda lugenud.
Õpetaja: Seal sa seal taaski sees oli Siis põhimõtteliselt mingisugust üksjagu juttu. Aga põhimõtteliselt hakkasid kohe üsna varakult tulema. Konferensi lingid, mis võivad, kus on igasugust informatsiooni veel juures süsteemi käitumine. Mingid diagrammid asjad ja nii edasi. Mingid kirjeldused. Ja loomulikult siis lingi. Sees on link ja lingi sees on link, et nagu see vana Hea,
Õpetaja: Ee, Rabbit Hole. Vaata, et tead vanasti, kui arendaja, kui ei olnud.
Õpetaja: Jah, vanasti oli niimoodi. Näiteks tahtsid mingit asja õppida, Võtsid mingi Kuulis või midagi? Wikipedia leht oli lahti.
Õpetaja: Sobib, Davai Vaatan sealt. Siis sa vaatad Loed esimese lause ära. Siin on mingid sõnad, mida üldse Pole kuulnud. Ei tea On ju et selge on see, et seal pole otse tõlgeid, vaid see on kontseptsioon või idee. Vaata, on ju, et
Õpetaja: siis, on see, et Paned Google selle sõna. Hakkad selle kohta lugema. Wikipedia lahti. Seal tuleb mingi liigid asju, et lõpuks sa võtad. Mis Asi, see on. Kogu aeg otsid. Otsid lõpuks, jõuad siis lugeda mingisuguse ühe lehe niimoodi. Ära. Kus enamvähem kõike seda asju aru Vaata, Et Ei ole nagu see, et järgmine link sa. Nagu.
Õpetaja: Kuhu ma nüüd lähen? Vaata, onju? Aga üks link tagasi. See taas, kui sain Päris palju informatsiooni. Ülipalju segadust Aa, ülikeeruline. Kõik olid sellega stressa. Analüütik, teised arendajad ja nii edasi keeruline. Lihtsalt paganama keeruline. Oli
Õpetaja: Ja mul oli Siis niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: see on väike õppetund Ka teile, onju? Ee, mina olin kodus. Vaata ja saja viiekümnendat korda ma tegelikult lugesin taaski Hommikul ärkad Ühes. Sa loed taaski täid seda Rapid hol I Üritad hoida nagu mingisugust pilti oma peas, Nagu mida? Kuidas? Mismoodi?
Õpetaja: Kui te Üritad oma taaskist aru saada? Täpsemalt, Nüüd sa teed koodibaasi lahti. No alguse pool oli see, et kuhu kurat ma üldse koodi kirjutan või Mida ma tegema pean, On ju
Õpetaja: Aa eriti Mõn on see. Vaata, isegi kui sa tahad koodi kirjutada, küsid stsenerilt väikest nõu, et, noh, Kuhu kataloogi? Mis failid? Kumb? Kuhu see asi hakkab elama?
Õpetaja: Kuhu iganes pärast tõstame ringi.
Õpetaja: Okei, no pane siis kuhu iganes, aga panen täitsa Savid, Pane lihtsalt sinna. Tee mingi uue kataloogi. Hakkad mässama tegelt tead Raudselt läheb kuhugi mujale, onju? Aga on ju Ja see on niimoodi. Sa oled kõike seda. Ja siis sa hakkad kirjutama sinna mingeid mõtteid maha. Vaata, hakkad koodi kirjutama, onju? Ja kogu see tsükkel on ülimalt Ülimalt habras, nagu.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd sa pead nagu saama aru, kus see süsteemi sisse tuleb, Millega ta peab arvestama. Kuidas mina pean kirjutama, kui Sa oled ise juba paar rida koodi kirjutanud. Nüüd pead seda ka veel mõtlema. Vaata
Õpetaja: ja sellega on niimoodi, et siis nagu, et ainult Üks klõks, vaata. Ja siis see kogu kaardimaja kukub kokku. Ongi niimoodi. Toimetad teed seal Vaata ja siis tuleb naine sisse. Põmm uks lahti. Tead, mis Maie ütles, Vä, mul on niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Siis hüppab uksa kinni. Ja kui üldse ukse kinni paneb tavaliselt. Läks uks lahti ka veel Onju Põmm minema sealt, onju? Mul on nagu
Õpetaja: nagu oleks puuga pähe saanud. Vaata, nagu. Vot mida. See on nagu see, et sa tahaks avastuses. Vaata, onju? Sa nagu lihtsalt kõik. Nagu sa ei suuda nagu seda kõike nagu peas, nagu hoomata ja haarata, ja siis on nagu See, et mida ma nüüd siis teen, nagu onju.
Õpetaja: No võibolla läheb natuke kiiremini. On ju, et, ee. Tegelikult sa olid ikka täiesti Crazy. Vaata ja
Õpetaja: muidugi kontoris. Tavaliselt on Niukene asi. Kui sul kõrvaklapid on kellegil peas, siis tähendab seda, et ta nagu ära tüüta, tavaliselt seda ei ole kuskil kirjutatud lahti, aga see on nii. Kui inimesel on kõrvaklapid peas, siis tähendab
Õpetaja: noh, otse nagu kohta. Vaata, kui te lähete Ka selles mõttes, et abi tuleb alati küsida. Ärge olge need inimesed, kes kolm päeva tiksuvad mõttetu asja taga kinni. Selle asemel, et korra minna küsida. Liigu edasi sellele. Niimoodi tulen aitan. Vaata, nagu peab oskama küsida. Aga abi tasub küsida siis, kui inimene läheb mingi kohvi võtma Või midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Või tahad nagu vetsu?
Õpetaja: Parem, kui ta vetsus tuleb välja. Võibolla onju aa, et ee, et küsida nagu abi, onju nagu siuksel hetkel. Sellepärast, et see võib olla väga häiriv, kui sa oled nagu nii nagu fokusseeritud. Ja sa üritad nagu mingi mõttelõnga hoida,
Õpetaja: meil oli. Meil oli Isegi Pigem oli niimoodi, et kui inimesel kõrvad klapid peas hiljem, et. Noh, väike nüanss. Vaata aga, see on parem, Variant saab notification Id maha keerata. Vaata, kui ta tõesti tahab keskenduda.
Õpetaja: Aga Ja üldiselt oli nagu niimoodi. Tegelikult, on kõige parem moment on see, Kui sa näed, et inimesed siis pläkutavad omavahel, siis lihtsalt lähed vahele ja ütled, kas sa saad korra mind aidata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga palun Ärge, kui te tõesti lähete, Ärge ärge jääge väikeste asjade taha kinni. Te peate muidugi. Tasakaalu ka valima. Aa, kui sina lähed abi paluma, Siis ole valmis siukesteks küsimusteks.
Õpetaja: Kas sa ise seda googeldasid? Kui su vastus on, ei, siis on. Kas sa vaatasid seda olemasolevat koodibaasi äkki midagi. Leiad mingit näidet või sarnast? Asja on ju? Ei,
Õpetaja: mis sa ei ole seda teinud. No nüüd, Chatch ja muude asjade, No, kus lubatakse. Vaata, ei ole, et selles mõttes, et kui sa vastad igale asjale. Jah, jah, vaata siis. Tere tulemast. Vaata, on ju Ilmselt sa Oled oma avenüüd nagu ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, tavaliselt rusikareegel. Tegelikult peaks olema niimoodi. Kui te olete ikka juba tund aega, olete nagu tegelikult ei ole liikunud edasi. Aa, siis. Tegelikult on aeg minna juba veits küsima. Aga seal on natuke nagu see, et see võib olla,
Õpetaja: saad kuskilt mingi informatsiooni. Sa vahepeal midagi. Proovid? Sa nagu tunned, et sa kuidagi nagu oled lähemal lähemal, et see võib hakata niimoodi venima venima venima, aga See võib venida tundide tundide päevade pikkuseks. Ja lõpuks, kui sa oled mingi uus inimene, nagu Aa, lõpuks hakatakse küsima, See on see, et Ma olen mingi kinni mingi asja. Juures. Okei? Noh, tule, räägime. Vaatame, on ju?
Õpetaja: Näidatakse, räägitakse, liigud edasi. See kõik oleks saanud olemata, siis Tuleb halb imidž. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: mina olin lihtsalt nii neetud. No see oli minu viga. Ma räägin kogemusest. Mina olin neetult uhke inimene, Vaata, et Mina ei läinud abi küsima, enne kui ma olin. Kõik asjad nagu ära ja tihtipeale. See asi võis niimoodi tegelt jääda venima, tegelt abi Tasub ka küsida siis, kui inimene metsust välja tuleb. Näiteks onju.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, Taaski tuleb lugeda. No lugesime me selle kiirelt. Läbi. Vaatame, et Et meil on mingi vaade, mis pealt reageerib ee sellele kaldkriipsule. Ja selle asja nimi peaks olema Home View
Õpetaja: ja meil peaks olema niimoodi, Et, Ee, mida iganes peale seda taaski, peaks olema meil ainult navigatsiooni menüüs. Üks variant on. See on kodu
Õpetaja: ja siis võiks midagi kuvada, Mingit teksti ja meelega on siin Niukene pilt, kus on Kaina? Nagu Kaks veerkrupp.
Õpetaja: No läks kaup.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme rakenduse lahti ja siis hakkame vaatama, et. Ee. Kuidas kuret see asi üldse tegelikult nagu töötab
Õpetaja: Frontend I kaust on? Mis on meil vaja? Front peaks töötama. Meil,
Õpetaja: Ee, Siin on Niukene kataloog nagu Source. Siin on kogu lähtekood. Ehk siis see kood ise, mis niiöelda midagi toimetab ja teeb,
Õpetaja: siin on olemas Niuke kataloog. Nagu Views.
Õpetaja: Vaated siia peaksid minema. Siis niuksed failid, mis reageerivad siis mingi konkreetsele rajale Urlis,
Õpetaja: et näidata mingit konkreetset sisu, siin Ongi meil juba üks niukene asi olemas. Nagu.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra siia sisse.
Õpetaja: On siin Ee, meil template. Block, Ma korra tõmban ülejäänud asjad siin, Nagu kokku. Meil on üks otsustuskoht. Ka ma varsti räägin sellest ka. See template Block on siis see osa,
Õpetaja: mis on ha, kuhu sisse Käib Html siia. Javascript ei käi siia käib ainult Html.
Õpetaja: Kogu selle vaate nähtava osa koodi mõttes peab olema. Nende kahe vahel on hea Tava
Õpetaja: on hea tava. Vanasti oli see reegel ja asjad läksid katki, et selles ühes template niiöelda tagide vahel tohib olla maksimaalselt üks Child Element
Õpetaja: on siin. Üks div on.
Õpetaja: On üks child.
Õpetaja: Kui mina paneks siia praegu ühe Tv juurde
Õpetaja: siis tegelikult enam ei ole. Üks tiiv. Vanasti läks asi lausa katki. Nüüd on nagu kind its. Not nice. Ja mingid asjad võivad valetada. Noh, me saame ju alati teha ühe Tv I lihtsalt sinna template vahele, kui vaja
Õpetaja: jah
Õpetaja: on kohtad.
Õpetaja: Kas ennem? Vähemalt? Ee. Ma jään vastuse võlgu aga me isegi ei, sa Lihtsalt värvid Let S Go on. Homme vaatame
Õpetaja: ma praegult. Ei tea, aga ma lihtsalt ei tahaks Nagu viimased tundi vihte teist selle peale kinni panna. Vaatame paremas asja, on ju?
Õpetaja: See on nagu mingi asi, mida ma ei tea. Ja ma ei oska. Nagu ütleme, et see pole standard. Olukord.
Õpetaja: Investi käitumine võtab aega. Võtsid uue haru. Proovi restarti. Esiteks alustame. Sellega.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma alustaksin pigem intellisele, Prooviks teha lihtsalt restardi Ja vaataks, kuidas sees on
Õpetaja: nii? Aga jah, ma ütlen, et lahendame nüüd tehnilise muresid. Ee, homme. Täna tahab midagi kaasa võtta ja aega Selleks pole
Õpetaja: nüüd kõik see osa. Kui teha see rakendus lahti siis praegult ongi Home View. See on koduvaade. See asub rajal kaldkriips,
Õpetaja: kus see tekst tuleb, kui vaadata seda sama Dv. I.
Õpetaja: See on kodu. Vaade asub rajal. Kaldkriips. On see sama tekst?
Õpetaja: Järgmine osa siin näitab, See on komponent. Seda saab igal pool korduvalt kasutada. Näeme, et on Niukene Hall komponent. Kui me lähme näiteks testvaatale, siis seal on see Sama asi
Õpetaja: korduvalt saab taaskasutada, On nii erineval vaatel ühel vaatel. Isegi. Mitu korda see on komponent? Kui me tuleme selle home vaate juurde tagasi Siis me näeme, et meil ongi siin näiteks niuke asi nagu test komponent.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: nüüd, et seda asja natukene lihtsustada, siis kõige esimene Samm on, et see võib olla Vaatamise koht või kaastamise koht, oleks see, et ma kustutaksin praegult kogu selle möga ära vaata ja hakkaks Nagu nullist pihta.
Õpetaja: Oota nüüd vist läks natukene palju.
Õpetaja: No ma võtan ikkagi kõik ära ja teeb siia viisakalt ühe Tv sisse. Lihtsalt üks Niisugune olukord.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Aa, üks keyboard shortcut ka. Õigemini. Kolm korraga erinevate erinevate toksimistega.
Õpetaja: Kood kipub minema meil ühel või teisel hetkel kuidagi valesti, Et nagu taanded Ja asjad ta tehniliselt töötab. Mingit probleemi Pole niikuinii. Nagu lõppfailis surutakse need asjad kokku, on ju aga lihtsalt, ei ole Nagu tava. Näiteks, et kas ma praegu saaksin väga hästi aru. Vaata, kes on keelelaps. Vaata, kui siin on mingisugused asjad on nagu nihkes,
Õpetaja: Siis on olemas Niukene kombinatsioon. Vaata, kui all on.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme niimoodi, et kustutage siin skriptide vahel asi ka Kõik ära,
Õpetaja: teeme hästi, toon Lihtsalt, ee, Template ja Unscript
Õpetaja: ja. Ja Templeti sees on vähemalt üks tiiv lihtsalt. Ja ainult üks tiiv, nagu hästi lihtne,
Õpetaja: kõik siit kaob eest ära. Vaata, See on meie mõte.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Ee, Kui kirjutan selle. Tere, vaata. Siis ta peaks tulema siia. Tere, on siin ääres vastab. Tõele on?
Õpetaja: Ma alustan. Esiteks sellest. Vaata, et, ee, miks. Miks ta nagu praegult selle tühja kaldkriipsu raja peale tuleb,
Õpetaja: kui ma kirjutan, näiteks siia. Noh, mis teine asi oli? Test vist oli, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui on test, siis me läheme kuhugi teisele vaatajale. Vastatajale, kui ma tulen lihtsalt Siia, kaldkriips. Ehk Kodu
Õpetaja: Noh, Brauser sööb selle ühe kaldkriipsu Ära aga taustal ta tegelikult on. On see. Tere, vaade see töötab niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et, No kui minna nüüd päris algusesse. Meil on siin indeks Atml.
Õpetaja: Kogu see osa, mis siin on head meta ja asi tuleb, selle, Need On need oranžid kaaned
Õpetaja: siin viitab, et kuule, et järgmine ülemine osa tuleb Id äpiga. See on veel ee, Tema Selle tehnoloogia enda sisemine Niiöelda seadistus Meil on Niukene klass, Nagu teeme korra Selle lahti.
Õpetaja: See äpp poes on samamoodi. On template ja on Script. I osa on Nii,
Õpetaja: siin template sees hakkab pihta mingi asi nagu Namn Navn Nav.
Õpetaja: Siin Navi. Sees on routerlink. Pank on rooterlink. Home Routerlink test,
Õpetaja: See Nüüd tegelikult on need kolm linki siin.
Õpetaja: Pank Own test.
Õpetaja: Siin on need ära defineeritud.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole veel selles mõttes mingit erilist hookus pookust, et see router ring töötab, niimoodi, et mis iganes on selle, too sees
Õpetaja: sinna rajale. Link viib, mis iganes on nende kahe tag, I Vahel on. Lingi nimi on siin Linginimi Home,
Õpetaja: kuhu Ta. Läheb?
Õpetaja: Kaldkriipsule
Õpetaja: on siin. Ee, niiöelda Link nimega Test. Need on need kaks tükki siin. Kuhu tema läheb kaldkriips? Test on nii,
Õpetaja: kui mina vajutan siia. Vaadake, Browser It üleval. Kui mina vajutan testi peale, tuli see test.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan home peale. Minnakse sellele rajale. Vat pole, Vajutasid nupu. Linki Kirjutasid? Ise. Vaata, mõte on sama, mida ma näha tahan. Tahan kodu vaadet näha.
Õpetaja: Nii kui see Navo sa nüüd ära niiöelda, et kõik meil on põhimõtteliselt näeme alati kõike mis on indeksi sees ja Äpi sees.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see rida. Kakskümmend on see, kus Magic hakkab juhtuma.
Õpetaja: See ütleb nagu. Seda. Vaata, et, ee, kõik,
Õpetaja: et põhimõtteliselt indeks kõik Mis on indeksi? Sees on? Alati sees. Kõik, mis on äpi sees, on alati seal templetis olemas. Aga nüüd see rida kakskümmend on, ütleb seda. See on nüüd seal sisse ehitatud. Funktsionaalsused. Ülejäänud Html tuleb vastavalt ruudile. Kus sa oled
Õpetaja: kui mina olen praegu siin testis, Näiteks
Õpetaja: siin on, Ee, selline niiöelda kast. Siin on selline. Okei, me alustame lihtsalt. Mit teret. Hetkel näeb ühte
Õpetaja: See tuleb tänu sellele, et ee, laetakse Vastavalt ruudile Koduvaade. Võibolla tulen selle Dublitseerimise juurde kohe tagasi, et et kuidas see siis nagu nüüd töötab? Vaata, kuidas on nüüd, niimoodi, et Siin on kirjas. Ja kui keegi asub kuskil rajal, siis laetakse mingi komponent või vaade?
Õpetaja: Meil on siin Niukene klass. Ee, nagu, ee, siin Noh, kõigepealt on kataloog nimega Ruuter. Tee jagaja.
Õpetaja: Kui sa lahti teha, siis siin on indeks punkt Cs.
Õpetaja: Me kutsume edaspidi seda Ruuteri indeksit seda faili.
Õpetaja: Kui see lahti teha, siis siin sees ongi Nüüd, see, koht,
Õpetaja: kuidas seotakse erinevad vaated, mis on vaate all radadega.
Õpetaja: Meil on Siin Niukene asi nagu Roots.
Õpetaja: Kui mina kustutan selle praegult selle osa ära, jääb Kast.
Õpetaja: Kas tähendab massiivi? See Tähendab seda et siin võib olla Mitu objekti Samasugused objektid. Aga need võib olla mitu kontoretset Iga me vaatame. Me näeme, et siin on tegelikult kaks objekti.
Õpetaja: Siin on Üks objekt, jutt loogilisest sulust, loogilise suluni koma ja on teine.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame, mis nende sees on, siis Iga objekti sees on nüüd meil mingisugused parameetrid.
Õpetaja: Paav rada, pruudi nimi ja on komponent,
Õpetaja: mis reageerib ja laetakse sellele rajale.
Õpetaja: See siin on üks peamiseid kohti, mis Ee puudutab seda, et missugused urlid me välja mõtleme ja mis vaated nende peale avanevad.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen selle alumise lahti, kui sina lähed rajale, test
Õpetaja: Siis avaneb komponent. Testview. See fail siin.
Õpetaja: Kui sina lähed rajale lihtsalt kaldkriipsek, mitte midagi siis on Homeview komponent, mis laetakse,
Õpetaja: kui mina Korra kustutan ära, et teha see asi näiteks. Ee. Uuesti.
Õpetaja: Te näete üleval seda importrida. Testview. Ma kustutan korra selle ka ära. Kujutame ette, et meil oli ainult see Home View siin. Vaata, niiöelda see ei ole Parekaasi tegemise koht on lihtsalt vaatamine. Mina ütlen, et teeme sellest olemasolevast objektist ühe Dublikaadi.
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et ee, teeme niimoodi, et kui keegi läheb rajale test,
Õpetaja: siis selle esiteks selle rajaseadistuse nimi on. See tuleb Siit taaskist taaskist on öeldud. Vaata, et ee. Kasutame.
Õpetaja: Kasuta Ruuteri indeksi nei ruuteri indeksis. Niiöelda Ruutide name osas konventsiooni. Oleks ta Tegelikult näidises olnud lihtsalt home.
Õpetaja: Aga kunagi hiljem selgub see teile, Miks on parem niimoodi, et selle nimel on natukene selgitavad teksti juures, kuna ta on ruut. Nad on ju ruutide massiiv.
Õpetaja: Teda on home, sest et meil neid home ja asju on veel. Vaata, Home View, Aga see on Home Root, et neid asju natukene eristada, siis selline nimi on Kogu see asi tegelikult töötaks ka ilma selleta kui vaja, aga, noh, ei, See. On. See on hea asi, mis siin on. Neile meeldib, et seda saab nime anda. See selgub kunagi hiljem, Miks,
Õpetaja: kui mina ütlen, et et on rada test, Panen talle nimeks, et see on test. Root.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus, et mis komponendile ta laeb.
Õpetaja: Ma kustutan praegu selle siit ära ja hakkan suurte tähtedega kirjutama. T ja V, et ta juba aitaks natuke valida mul neid komponente lihtsamalt. Ma ei kirjuta kogu teksti välja. T. V,
Õpetaja: Siis ta pakub igasuguseid asju, mida ta pakub. Ta pakub testview.
Õpetaja: Vaadake nüüd rida. Kolme hetkel ei ole siin Mingit importi. Ma kustutasin ära.
Õpetaja: Kui ma valin selle Testview,
Õpetaja: siis siia tuli testview, aga ülesse tuli automaatselt importrida, See põhimõtteliselt selgitab, et mida See asi täpselt tähendab.
Õpetaja: Ee, see tähendab. Seda
Õpetaja: väikene selgitus. Vähemalt nüüd. Voes on niimoodi ät märgistusega. Kui meil on mingid rajad ja kaardistused, Ätt viitab alati source kataloogile
Õpetaja: Ülihea, et on niuke süsteem
Õpetaja: mõnes kohas. Vaata, kui ma ennem sain. Ma ei saanud aru, kas ma pean panema mingi kaldkriips public. Ja siis tuleb see kaardipilt, Vaata et nagu segadus siin selles niiöelda raamistikus on lihtne igasugustel radadel. Ätt viib koju, Ta nüüd ütleb seda, et Testview reageerib kataloogile Views Mis on siin selle source sees?
Õpetaja: Näed, vaitan. Ätt. I Ma panen korra kõik kinni,
Õpetaja: Panen kõik siit kinni niimoodi. Kui ma vajutan äpi peale, mis avaneb
Õpetaja: Source kataloog. Olen aktiivsed selle peal. Siin sees on Views, on nii, Kui ma vajutan Views peale,
Õpetaja: siis avaneb see kataloog. See defineerib lihtsalt neid katalooge ja faile. Ja kui see viimane asi see viitab juba Testview.
Õpetaja: Niiöelda Ee, failile.
Õpetaja: Ee, et siis see koht on see maagiline koht, kus kaks asja seotakse omavahel,
Õpetaja: et kui tuleb mingisugune aadress, kuhu Tahad minna, siis ava selline vaade.
Õpetaja: Nii tulles nüüd tagasi selle indeks Atml. Ile, mis viitab äp Ile. Kus sees on see? Ee, navigatsiooni menüü. Ma olen selle kokku tõmmanud praegu. Siin, onju?
Õpetaja: Siis nüüd on, niimoodi et meil on see navigatsiooni menüü seal. Navigatsiooni menüü
Õpetaja: kui ma Seda Dubleeriksin seda navigatsiooni müünd. Mitu korda
Õpetaja: oleks neid või? Ee, natuke oleks haavasti.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teeks siin peal tublid käite, on kaks korda,
Õpetaja: Kui ma tõmbaks selle kokku ja teeks veel ühe. Tublid
Õpetaja: on juba kolm korda, on ju? Saate aru, nii Aga nüüd on hoopis see, et Meile öeldakse, et meil saab olema see navigatsiooni menüü ja ülejäänud osa tuleb vastavalt lihtsalt ruudile.
Õpetaja: Hetkel meil homevused on lihtsalt tere mina Ütleksin, et kuule
Õpetaja: järgnevalt. No paneme kolm korda. Tuleb sisu vastavalt ruudile.
Õpetaja: Siis sinu jaoks teretere. Tere,
Õpetaja: ma võtan korra selle tagasi, on ju, et on ainult üks. Tere, vaatame seda varianti. Siin on Punane Hall komponent Mingi tekst Gift. Taaskasutatud komponent.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tuleksin praegult, paneksin seda Routerview D.
Õpetaja: Kaks korda on need juba kaks korda,
Õpetaja: et see on lihtsalt süsteem. Vaata, et kokkuvõttes pannakse see Html kokku dünaamiliselt, loomulikult me ei soovi, et neid oleks mitu korda kumbagi. Vaid me soovime neid. Ongi mõlemad üks kord, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga te saaksite, aru, et ülejäänud kood Tuleb vastavalt sellele, kus sa asud, loja mõttes.
Õpetaja: No kui mina tahaks teha mingisuguse vaate juurde vaatamise koht. Ee, teen ühe Voe komponendi juurde. Panen ta nimeks mingi.
Õpetaja: Mina ei tea About. Näiteks About View selle panga kohta midagi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen uue vaate ja panen siia template bloki. Ee, ja panen siia. Lihtsalt About. Näiteks.
Õpetaja: Kas ma saan kuidagi seda praegult näha?
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa seda näha. Ma võin kirjutada siia ülesse Urile ka näiteks. About
Õpetaja: Pole Midagi näidata
Õpetaja: miks. Ei ole mitte midagi näidata sellepärast? Et, siin selles kaardistuses ei ole selle kohta ööd Ega mütsi. Kui ma tahaksin, siis ma teeksin siia ühe juurde. Ma ütleksin, et Davai teeme niimoodi, et Rajala Bout
Õpetaja: tuleb vaade, Kustutan selle siit ära
Õpetaja: A ja V et oleks tihtem valida. About View Reale Nelile Reale. Neli tuleb import,
Õpetaja: mis viitab konkreetselt sellele failile.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuli About on home test
Õpetaja: ja mul ei ole ühtegi. Linki Ei ole. Mis About ile. Aga see ei tähenda, et ma ei saaks ise kirjutada About
Õpetaja: ja ta läheb. Sinna.
Õpetaja: See Router View. Ee, Vabandust, see ruuteri indeks on siis see koht, kus meie saame põhimõtteliselt siis manipuleerida Seda,
Õpetaja: mis mingisugusele rajale, mida kuvatakse.
Õpetaja: Üli lihtne süsteem. Tegelikult ülimõnus.
Õpetaja: Mõtled mingi uue vaate välja? Mõtle Mingi rada välja, on ju? Panen need kokku
Õpetaja: Ee, teed uue vaatekomponendi Proged seal natuke. Html I projed seal natukene java Script I mõnedüansid juurde ja imelihtne,
Õpetaja: ülilihtne vanasti, kui oli. Nagu see päris. Ee Üheksakümnendate stiilis niiöelda patsiga. Poisid ja asjaarmastajad, kes tegid veebilehte ja olid need mitmed lehed, siis seal see linkimine ja Asjade üle kandmine oli ülikeeruline. Igatepidi,
Õpetaja: kui kuskil mingi rada muutus. Sa pidid seal mingi faili nimesid muutma. Jumal teab, mida sajas kohas linke muutma. Siin on lihtsalt ainult üks koht, kus on ära defineeritud. Nagu põhimõtteliselt see, et kui sa lähed ühele vaatajale, siis kus see stardipauk, Nagu hakkab pihta,
Õpetaja: kui ma täna Kui ma nagu mõtlen. Mul ei ole sada kohta. Kui ma täna nagu tahan, tänu sellele name ile Või niimoodi targalt logeda. Kui tuleb, ütleb, et ei ei sobi, et ma tahan, et ta meie kohta
Õpetaja: Ma tahan, et Url oleks selline.
Õpetaja: Tule siia, muuda ära, tšilli. Billy pole mitte midagi keerulist.
Õpetaja: See on väga hea ja see annab väga hea ülevaate ka.
Õpetaja: Kõik kõik niiöelda Vaated, mis on, on, mis on, vähemalt nähtavad. Või võiksid olla nähtavad idee järgi kasutajale. Siis nad on siin kirjas
Õpetaja: Leids isegi lausa dokumentatsiooni eest, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma võtan need sammud siit tagasi.
Õpetaja: Kustutan Selle About View ka ära.
Õpetaja: Mida võibki teha, on nüüd on ka see tegemise koht on Siis see, et. Ee. Esiteks seda testview D. Meil ei ole vaja
Õpetaja: et saadame selle kaustalt Ee, hingusele.
Õpetaja: Mine saa ka.
Õpetaja: Ja kui see rada veel siin on, Siis kustutame selle ära ka. Selle testview raja. Lohisev Koma on siin lubatud. Failis ei ole lohisev Koma, Mis Asi on lohisev koma.
Õpetaja: No siin on ju Vaata, üks objekt. Tema lõpus on koma, aga järgmist objekti ei tule.
Õpetaja: Ee, siim ja javascriptis saab teha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Jason File saadab siin. See on viimane komponent. Kui ma panen siia praegult, panen lohiseva koma treiling komma
Õpetaja: siis kui kuskilt Sõnumid, süsteemid vahetaksid seda sõnumit omavahel. Siis tuleb mingi viga. Vaata, et see ei ole valiidne. Jason.
Õpetaja: Seal andmedokumendis ei saa olla lohisevat koma, Viimasel ei ole koma, aga meil programmeerides saame seda teha Ja ongi mõistlik see jätta kui. Järgmine kord teed sööd, nagu tublid kraadi vaata. Kui mõnus on koma, on kohe vahel. Ja Koma on lõpus. Iga kord on koma.
Õpetaja: Kas siin kohal on küsimusi? Selle ruutindeksi kohta? Kuidas See töötab
Õpetaja: ooteid.
Õpetaja: Jah, et kuhu tahab minna, sinna Pius
Õpetaja: Ja täpselt Angelina või Angeliina Angelina? Jah, Angeliina. Nagu, on, nagu, täpselt, see mis sa ütlesid, ongi see, et Sinna Views Ee, tausta alla. Saad teha uusi vaateid, Saad kujundada selle nii nagu vaja.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd selles ruutingus, Saad need kaks asja omavahel ühendada.
Õpetaja: Ja Nüüd kui me läheme tagasi sinna. App. Ee, voefaili. Vaata, mis on osa nendest ee, oranžidest, niiöelda Oranžidest Aa
Õpetaja: kaantest, et on alati igas vaates.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis siia. Me saame siis lihtsalt neid linke teha, et kus need lingid on, kui Me tõmbame veits kokku. See esimene on nagu patt, onju? Mingi see veits justkui oleks logoga. Tegelt ei ole onju et siin, on need Lingid home ja test.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on siis see koht. Ee, kus. Kui me tahame, et kasutaja saab ise kuhugi klikkida, Me peame neid siia lisama juurde, on ju? Aga hetkel on just hoopis ülesanne, et Ee, taaski. Ütles, et peab jääma ainult üks ja ainus ja tema nimi on kodu.
Õpetaja: Me tulemegi siis siia. Mis me selle alumisega teeme?
Õpetaja: Kustutame ära. Ee, ja siin teeme väikse muudatuse, Mitte home, vaid
Õpetaja: kodu, et sisu on Eesti keelne, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd see on Paigas on kodu. Kõikide saad, onju?
Õpetaja: Väga tore.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui proovida näiteks ise manipuleerida, et panen Siin test. On ju siis? Ei, ta ei vii kuhugi, meid Onju Meil ei ole enam siin, midagi
Õpetaja: pole olemas,
Õpetaja: Okei, Lähme taski juurde tagasi Nüüd on missioon. Ee, tahame teha samamoodi, et see on minu pank ja paneme hoopis mingi Gif I see on minu. Ma käisin kunagi Inglismaal, kui ma elasin pikalt. Ee, Niukene Laadne muusikafestival. Tundub, et nurr oli juba siis mingi teema.
Õpetaja: Ee, ühesõnaga paneme Mingi Gif I Kuhugi Mingi pildi. Nüüd me tuleme selle. Me oleme ära nüüd saanud aru. Vaata, et tegelikult meil on siin kenasti toimiv süsteem. Nüüd on üks otsustuskoht.
Õpetaja: Mulle õudsalt meeldib teha niimoodi, et ee, üleval pool on template osa, kus Käib Html, kood, ja visuaal
Õpetaja: ja Allpool on script.
Õpetaja: Tegelik. Tava on vastupidi.
Õpetaja: Ja ma. Arvan, et on aeg teha Ka Minul See esimene grupp, kus me tõstame selle asja Nii nagu on tava.
Õpetaja: Ee, see see variant, nagu minule meeldib. Vaata, nagu see, et visuaalne pool on üleval ja funktsionaalsus on all on Niukene disainer. Approach.
Õpetaja: Et sulle meeldib näha seda visuaalset asja kuidagi eespool. Vaata, sa keskendud sellele. Ja kogu funktsionaalsus elab seal ümber selle
Õpetaja: aga tegelikult See ei ole üldse loogiline. Ee, selles mõttes. Ma olen mõelnud, et miks on nagu vastupidist, aga mulle tundub niimoodi just nagu mõnusam. See on minu nii öelda. Variant tundub alati mõnusam. Ja. Aga enam ma, nagu, ee, ma saan aru, miks
Õpetaja: see on sellepärast, et tegelikult, Kui mõelda. Ee, kuidas inimene asju loeb, Ta loeb ülevalt alla Okei, see on nagu Captain Obvious
Õpetaja: aga seal, funktsionaalsuses tihtipeale ongi see Vaata Et ennem kui me midagi kuvame. Me peame saama mingisugused andmed ja asjad. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, mida kuvatakse. Ja seal on nagu mingid sõnumite saatmised Ja asjad, et tihtipeale tegelikult on mingisugused eeltegevused.
Õpetaja: Eeltegevused enne kui üldse on Nagu vaja. Mõelda, mida me mida me nüüd näeme
Õpetaja: ja selles mõttes on see loogiline. Vaata, et kui sa tuled siia faili ja sa tahad saada aru, mis siin. Toimub,
Õpetaja: siis sa peadki natukene vaatama Kõigepealt, et kuule, mis siin nagu toimub.
Õpetaja: Ja alles siis sa hakkad mõtlema. Noh, mingid andmed asjad tulevad, et mis sind siis nagu kuvatakse, ehk, Siis ee, see vana blokk, et ee, templeid üleval ja script all.
Õpetaja: Lähme, Lähme, nii, nagu tehakse enamus Production is
Õpetaja: sul on mingi Vahe ka laadimisel.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast ongi see template blokk. On Nagu väga spetsiifiline, et. Noh, seal käibki ainult Html et see, ee, see ee raamistik Ise nagu manageerib, Et mida ta täpselt tegema peab? Meil on seal mõned sõnad, kus me tegelikult isegi konkreetselt ütleme. Et Kuule, enne kui Sa hakkad templeid üldse rendendama.
Õpetaja: Mõned sõnad kaovad sõnavara. Seda kutsutakse renderdamiseks. Renderdamine võib justkui mõelda, et joonistab pilti. Valmis. Vaata, Vanasti oli üliaeglaselt Hägune pilt läheb jälle teravamaks. Vaata, on ju? Seda Võib ka enne renderdamiseks mõte. Aga meie mõtleme, seda, et kuidas ta. Millal ta hakkab Html I nagu kokku panema või mida? Seda osa hakatakse nagu vaatama ja kuvama niiöelda selle raamistiku poolt onju
Õpetaja: ee, et meil on nagu Tihtipeale siis tegelikult ennem, kui me tahame üldse midagi renderdada, me nagu ise. Nagu manipuleerime seda lauset. Ära hakka üldse seda, nagu sa nagu Räägid selle raamistikuga enne kui sa üldse hakkad siin midagi joonistama ja puhama lehel, Palun tõmba mingid andmed,
Õpetaja: Kui sa saad need kätte ja Ainult siis siis. Sellisel juhul hakkame joonistama. Näiteks onju? Ee, näitame kasutajale. Siis seda lehte. Enne pole pointigi. Ehk siis, kuidas see tuleb välja, ka. Vaadake, see tuleb üsna ruttu. Kui me teame parema klõpsu ja ütleme. Noh, see on vaatamise koht praegu ja ma valin New
Õpetaja: ja Vajan View komponent.
Õpetaja: Ta praegu küsib. Seda Koodi kirjutatakse tänapäeval kahte stiili. Üks on tehes Seda erinevus on. Ma räägin, siis saab olema, niimoodi et see. See kood on natuke teistsugune.
Õpetaja: Ja Option Shapia, mis on nagu veidi vanem. Meie kindlasti õpime ja teeme, sest et see on Lihtsam,
Õpetaja: Ma vahet pole, kumma valid. Ma panen mingi nime korra. Mingi temp. Ee, view.
Õpetaja: Valin. Ee, Noh, kui me nüüd vaatame seda ee, seda asja siis ta pani skripti ülesse pani
Õpetaja: ja template pani alla.
Õpetaja: Ei, no stiil, mida me tegelikult ei kasuta kunagi on niipidi ja Mina koguaeg tõstsin neid ümber ümber. Ümber. Vaata, Ega no more
Õpetaja: Ee. Teate seda kuulsat? Ee, legendaarset poksimatši. Kus, Ee, mis ta nimi oli, Ütles need kuulsad sõnad? Nomaz?
Õpetaja: No Noor
Õpetaja: poiss oli piisavalt saanud vastu hambaid. Talle aitas. Ee, selle asjaga on ka nüüd niimoodi. Aitab sellest Ee, lähenemisest, mis on nagu Design And First.
Õpetaja: See ei tähenda et keegi, ei kasuta seda. Ja üldse pole kasutatud. On ikka ee, aga Ma ütlengi et lihtsalt Mulle enne tundub ka mõistlikum see. Et, las See siis olla õigesti ehk. Mis, Me siin teeme on, siis? Võtame selle ülemise osa niimoodi
Õpetaja: siniseks kontrolliks.
Õpetaja: Ja toome siia hoopis alla.
Õpetaja: Mis on meil nagu mõnus asi. Siin, on see, et me saame neid asju niiöelda siin ära peita, kui asjad hakkavad liiga palju kasvama ja nii edasi. Aga see ei ole praegu Point kõik Selles mõttes visuaalselt ei puutu mitte midagi. Vaata, ma tulen selle kodu vaatele. See, Tere, on ikka siin samamoodi nagu alati.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ee,
Õpetaja: hästi kiired küsimused ja Kiired vastused. Mis on Html? I ee. Niiöelda eesmärk ja roll. Mis see Html meile annab?
Õpetaja: Noh, struktuuri ja sisu on ju, Ee, mida annab Cs, Ss.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga mootor? Ühte sõna veel. Tallinnas on hästi. Niukene universaalne ütles, et stiili.
Õpetaja: Vot see see teine sõna mulle praegu Mängis ka ja paigutuse.
Õpetaja: Kuidas on meil siin see paigutus praegult siin. Ee, see on Minu pank. On vasakul pool paremal. Pool on pildikene. Või Noh, kihv. Mida iganes tekst ei ole, ka päris vasakul vasakul vastatajale. No see on nagu näidis Siin muidugi, et me, ise, teha, mis tahame.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles mõttes.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas on? Ee, kuidas on meie veebilehel, Mis praegu, tundub, et kus see Tere, on?
Õpetaja: Täiesti vasakus nurgas. Nüüd, iga kord, kui me hakkame tegema mingit uut komponenti ja edaspidi see saab olema nii nagu me näeme ju. Vaata, onju, On suht tühjus. Seal on ju
Õpetaja: iga kord kui me hakkame nägema mingisugust. Aa, niukest asja.
Õpetaja: Ma Vaatan korra. Kas vaade jäi küll Jah, Ee, siis Meil on vaja nagu manipuleerida seda, vaata, et kuidas me paigutust saame mõjutada. No mis me just ütlesime, mille? Mille ülesanne oli paigutust kontrollida.
Õpetaja: Vot sa juba ütlesid kaks sammu ette ära, et vastus on Css. Vaata, Cs, Sss. Iga Teeme paigutust
Õpetaja: ja me ei hakka ise leiutama Mingisuguseid. Ee, Css Sätteid, et stiilisätteid vaid kasutame.
Õpetaja: Panete Googlesse uut strap
Õpetaja: No võib Css ka juurde panna, aga see otseselt ei ole vajalik Get Boots Trap lehele. Peame jõudma ühel või teisel viisil.
Õpetaja: Kuid kui te selle lehe teete lahti,
Õpetaja: siis kõige esimese asjana, mis te võiksite teha on kirjutada siia sisse või favorit? Selle ei pane, Grid.
Õpetaja: Mis tähendab Grid?
Õpetaja: Ruudustik. Bingo.
Õpetaja: Me maandume siis siia juba konkreetsete näidetega et Nüüd tuleb mingi niukene link, nagu siin on. Ee, näete, siin on see. Sellest. Ma räägin hiljem. Vaata, viis, punkt, kolm, bla, blabla. Kogu See asi on nagu aadress. Ja see on nagu kus sektsioonis me asume.
Õpetaja: Siin on selline Example, ees, kus on nagu, põhimõtteliselt kolm veergu. Enne kui sul üldse midagi hakkan jääppima ja rääkima, siis esimene liigus, Mis te teete, on? Te panete favorit siia alla
Õpetaja: selle koha,
Õpetaja: sest Me tuleme siia veel mitmeid ja mitmeid kordi. Ja kõige rohkem on see, et kui tuleb uus vaade, siis me alati peame hakkama. Mõtlema paigutusele. Ja me tahame kohe algusest peale oma disainis. Nagu manageerida mingit umbkaudset ruumipaigutust. Vähemalt
Õpetaja: Ta ei pea olema nagu lõplik variant, aga vähemalt, nagu et hoiame asja. Oh, ja ma olen tiimi projektides vanades projektides nähtud. Kus üldse, nagu ma sellega tegelen, Hiljem Alguses on ülirõve, kõik On mingi vasakul pool. Kõik on mingi üli uksis. Ükski kass pole värviline. Küll jõuab. Milleks? Hakkame Kohe Algusest peale, on ju?
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja teha paigustust. Ja see gridsüsteem on kõige lihtsam lihtsam. Lähenemusi on erinevaid, Aga see lahendus on lihtsalt lollikindel lihtne, Kuidas sa saad. Niukse tulemuse, nagu sa tahad.
Õpetaja: Nii. Kui te tulete siia, siis esimene asi, mis me teeme? Me võtame selle vana hea näite. No täna ta ei ole veel vana hea näide Aga varsti on ta teil. Kus on lihtsalt kolm veergu, Ühel real. Ja see Html näidiskood on siin all
Õpetaja: konteiner.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tulevad kolum Id, mis me teeme, Tuleme siia peale. Klik, klikk, klikk.
Õpetaja: Nii ee, Ja kuna kogu kogu see konteiner tegelikult Ee, saabki manageerima meie lehe paigutust. Siis ongi väga tšilli pilli.
Õpetaja: Kui ongi ta selle templeti sees
Õpetaja: ilma ta see konteineri. Kui me Paneme nüüd. Ma just kaotasin juba ära. Kuidagi, Control V,
Õpetaja: et on selline asi on ainult. Kas On ainult üks tiiv Siin sees
Õpetaja: on Ainult üks ta täielikult ka garanteerib meile ka, et see asi on meil nagu hästi. Ja nüüd see sama tekst, mis te näete, No Siin on mingid ruudud ja varjundid juures. Aga lihtsalt tekst kolme veeru peal, et kui nüüd vaadata lehekülge,
Õpetaja: on kolm, kolm kolm
Õpetaja: ja kuidas see töötab, on niimoodi, kui võtta natukene seda niiöelda pilbasteks. Kas vaatamise mõttes näete seda sinist? See on üks,
Õpetaja: kuidas ta saab, kuidas, miks ta on. Ja Miks need. On kolumnid? Kas te näete seda?
Õpetaja: Need viitavad Bootstrap I klassidele samamoodi. See
Õpetaja: Viitab. Noh, see oli minified variant. Vaata, ma panen mitte minified
Õpetaja: Näed, siin on Mingid. Siin on mingid sätted ja seaded. Teil ei ole vaja teada, kuidas, miks
Õpetaja: tehes lihtsalt Tive ja pannes neile sisse ja koll. Saame mängida niukse ruudustikuga, et kuidas asjad üksteise suhtes paiknevad.
Õpetaja: Ülilihtne idee saab sellega lihtsalt nagu tabelit teha, kui tahad, kui tahad, Tahab nagu põhimõtteliselt mängida, nagu. Vaata. Noh, meile on öeldud see, et ee, hetke seisuga, et peaks olema Niukene
Õpetaja: Kaks ruutu, ühel pool on tekst. Ja teisel pool on pilt.
Õpetaja: No mis me siis siin peaks tegema? Et nagu proovida seda asja teha
Õpetaja: Võtame ära, tulen siia, panen ühe kliki kuskile siia. Reale, aitan. Control X võtab Clipboard Ile Aga Tegelt katib, Ära on? Ju
Õpetaja: nüüd siin. Siin näites oli siin on öeldud, ka et mingi tekst on. See on meie äge pank. Hüüumärk.
Õpetaja: No mis reale kirjutan? Kui ma tahan, et läheks vasakpoolsesse.
Õpetaja: Esimesse, on ju? Noh, see on meie äge pank.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mis Mail I ka midagi nii
Õpetaja: saab kohe vaadata, See on meie äge pank, sobib. Noh, Kaine sobib
Õpetaja: siis siia. Teise Peaks tulema mingi pilt.
Õpetaja: No see tuleb natukene rohkem teksti, et lihtsalt Selle kolumni võiks nagu ära kustutada,
Õpetaja: Aga kohe kohe tasub tegelikult juba entrit vajutada et
Õpetaja: hakkame siis seda pilti siia sisse timmima,
Õpetaja: nüüd kui Mina ütlen, meil on elementi Ee, imidž vaja. Siis mis võiks olla meie esimene samm. Mis me nüüd teeme?
Õpetaja: Googel on peaaegu, aga veel parem.
Õpetaja: Kas ta on mingi ka visuaalne osa lehest, Bootstrap? Muidugi.
Õpetaja: Et. Ee. Tegelikult ju piltidel. Kas teil on mingid raamid? Varjundid? Mida iganes onju? Ärme hakka siin nagu leiutama Jalgratast, onju? Võtame, vaatame, mis on. Kas te nüüd saate aru, miks? Tegelikult ei ole isegi otseselt vaja, Nagu mäletada neid elemente nagu siukse detailsusega. Nagu me nagu läbi käime,
Õpetaja: et enamus näiteks niikuinii me vähemalt selle kursuse raames tuleme niikuinii siia Koodinäide on siis ees, Aga noh, loomulikult tahame olla nendega tuttavad,
Õpetaja: aga panna lihtsalt image see pakub juba responsi. Image, image, Thumbnails ja nii Edasi on ju responsive image?
Õpetaja: Ta vist suudab siis nagu ennast nagu väiksemaks teha. Tahad Thumbnaily teha? Siin on mingid näited. Jälle Saad vaadata Keskel oleks jaadi ja saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Tule otsi siit. Noh, see sama responsi image võiks meile sobida. Võib kaili panna, kui me tahame ta pigem selliseks väiksemaks teha. Vaata, visuaalis on. Need raamid on ka juures, onju?
Õpetaja: Võibolla Võtame selle.
Õpetaja: Copy To Clipboard.
Õpetaja: Tuleme, paneme siia.
Õpetaja: Nüüd On tal probleem? Muidugi, sorsiga. Sellepärast sealt. Ega ta tema näites ei teadnud kus meil, pilt tuleb, ja mis selle pildi nimi võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Me võime selle aldi kõigepealt ära teha. Vaata, et ee, aa, midagi mõnusat. Selles mõttes see Source võib olla mida iganes see ei pea olema ainult Jpg ja Bng. Ta võib ka Gif olla
Õpetaja: Lähme otsime midagi ägedat.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui mina otsin. Näiteks Ee,
Õpetaja: mina ei tea. No Ma iga kord panen midagi. Lampi. Cool Bank If.
Õpetaja: Noh, pildid.
Õpetaja: Kas on mõni Gif on ka vä?
Õpetaja: Noh, mis mitte. Ee, ma vaatan, Kas ma saan päriselt ka selle siit kätte? Copy. Image adres. Te võite mida iganes võtta.
Õpetaja: Ee, Coop. Image adressiga peab alati tšekkima. Tabis Kõigepealt, kas ta nüüd läheb veebilehele või? On päriselt pilt?
Õpetaja: See vist tundub et läks ju veebilehele.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole päris pilt.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma Siis siit kätte. Saan
Õpetaja: Äkki nüüd teist korda? Need kohad tahavad loomulikult Laiendi järgi. Juba näen, et see vist on õige.
Õpetaja: Ma võin, kes tahab. Ma võin Chat I panna Ka
Õpetaja: Kes tahab selle samaga mängida? Aga ma pärast kustutan ära, sest see on mingi mõttetu kräp, Ee, Niukene Link,
Õpetaja: et Kui ma. Nüüd võtan selle lingi, mis on isegi Gif,
Õpetaja: See hakkab tegelt päris kiire närvidel käima, Ma kujutan ette meil Sai aga lastes olla.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kui ma tulen, panen selle siia Source i alla selle lingi. Võibolla alti Kõigepealt. Ee, mingi tekst ka, et kui ei saa kuvada. Ee, lahe pank.
Õpetaja: Hoiupõrsas vajub põrsas.
Õpetaja: Hoiupõrsa.
Õpetaja: Lõime katki Mida iganes
Õpetaja: see on, see vaata, et hetkel tal ei ole ju mingit sisu, et kui pilti mingil põhjusel ei renderdaks,
Õpetaja: siis oleks, et pilt on katki. Ei lahe hoiu, põõrsa. Aa, s lööme ta katki. Väga futaalne.
Õpetaja: Nii ee, kui ma panen nüüd siia source. Kui nüüd on päris kihvli link, siis see tegelikult võiks töötada.
Õpetaja: Tuli siia.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et sellega võib ikka natuke liiga hulluks minna. Vaata, mis see on.
Õpetaja: See on juba päris hea
Õpetaja: Ma proovin uuesti Ee, Coop. Image adress. Ee, ma pakun, et see tegelikult veel viib veebilehele, aga siit ma saan juba õige lingi kätte
Õpetaja: ei saanud.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidas saab
Õpetaja: kuidagi ikka saab. Kuule, Comand, see alati saab. See on juba, kui ma juba näen seda asja siin, küll ma selle kätte saan. See tundub olevat õige.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: te tulete niikuinii varem või hiljem. Mulle järgi. Te saate kõik selle nii et mida iganes tal ka praegu pole.
Õpetaja: Paneme selle siia ja vaatan korra siis meie seda lehekülge.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, nii okei.
Õpetaja: Printsiibis. Nagu midagi töötab ja vist selle taaski võime isegi lüüa lukku. Vaatan taaski üle.
Õpetaja: Muutsime koduvaate all järgnevaks. Menüüsse. Peaks jääma kodu. Võibolla teksti kujul. Võiks Sellele eel kuvada mingit tekste mingit pilti. Kustuta Ebavajalikud. Hello, World. Asjad. Ee ruuti kasuks. Ka Niiöelda Root Name konventsiooni osas Kasutame Home Road On kõik tehtud.
Õpetaja: Vist peaks olema Tehtud küll, et oli ju Home Root üks asi. Ülejäänud asjad kustutasime ära
Õpetaja: Kuskilt vanast ajast on jäänud see tingimus, et Atml selle kustutame ka ära. Seda pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siis hakkame toimetama. Ee, on vaja lihtsalt ära kommitida, et te tulete selle komitee tööriistale,
Õpetaja: Nii, ja Siin Siis mina ei tea. Ma taas teen niimoodi. Mingi feb. Vana harjumus. Feb. Neli.
Õpetaja: Ee. Alustan Haru nimega. See on Niukene Lhv tava Fa Mail i complete.
Õpetaja: Nii nagu
Õpetaja: nii võite kõik ots ee potsutada õlale. Te olete just teinud. Läbi oma esimese eluarendustaski,
Õpetaja: kes sai, no Kes sai
Õpetaja: ja tähtis. Homme hommikul vaatame värske peaga peale. Ee, üritame aru saada. Täna tahaks nii palju, Kui saaks veel,
Õpetaja: Mis veel, Ee, Siis päriselus on niimoodi, et ta tegelikult see taaskond nagu staatuses. Ja seda saab muuta
Õpetaja: siin kõrval peidus. Hetkel on ta ei ole isegi kellegile sainitud. Ja ta on taskis to do
Õpetaja: ee. Kui korra minna nagu ee, sinna nagu boardvaatele,
Õpetaja: siis Ee, seda saab iga iga niiöelda organisatsioon. Saab seda ise püsti panna vaata. Et, mis on vaja läbi niiöelda ujuda
Õpetaja: ehk. Siis klassikaliselt ee. Näiteks. Lhv s Oli esimene Samm oli see, et analüüsimisel
Õpetaja: analüütik tegeles. Sellega oli staatus. Järgmine Samm oli see. Ee, Vist oli in development.
Õpetaja: Meil oli samme üritada natukene vähem on hoida, et ei ole Nagu et ei ole. See on mõtetu. Ee, liiga palju Swimmile ei näe.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis oli development. Siis oli Testing, testing ja lõpus juba vist oli ta tegelikult status. Complete
Õpetaja: jutt on vist mida Iganes. Mõte on sama,
Õpetaja: et see hakkab ju niimoodi ujuma seal taaski.
Õpetaja: Ja. Aga see. See on jälle. Vaata, siukene. Ee, protsess ja lähenemine on vastavalt siis sellele ettevõtte nagu arenduskultuurile, et kuidas Nemad asju teevad, et siin võib olla palju samme. Vaata Incode Review Ja mis iganes, vaata
Õpetaja: ja ta testimine on nagu reaalne samm, vaata, Onju, Mis on? Siin, oli ka tegelikult, mis oleks pidanud olema, on see. Noh, kui nüüd, nagu läbi mängida seda, saab kuna meil on Kõik jagatud taas ka, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis me ei saa nagu seda kuidagi personaalselt siin mängida. Aga idee järgi on siis niimoodi, et ee Esiteks oli. Ma panen.
Õpetaja: No jonnik valib nagu. Kellele see läheb.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin tuleks niimoodi. Sul on mingi töökaaslane, toomas, onju? Siis Sa kirjutad Toomas leiate ülesse ja paneb selle sulle klassikaliselt toomased. Gmail, mis see on,
Õpetaja: Ee, Keegi õnnelik, kes on selle emaili aadress saanud
Õpetaja: ee, et Et klassikaliselt see pigem oli. Niimoodi Vaata mingit tilulilu. Taaske Võid ju panna sulle niisama. Ja see tuleb su dashboard ile, kui sa logid Shirasse sisse. Sul kohe hüppab ette, nagu dashboard. Seal on kõik need taaskid, mis on sinu nimele pandud. Sa näed neid staatuseid pealkirju ja Mingeid. Noh, tilulilu. Näed, nagu
Õpetaja: ee. Ja päriselusse käib niimoodi. Et kui taas pannakse sinu nimele, siis enamus kohad Track Ivad tööaega. Olete sellise Kontseptsiooniga tuttavad.
Õpetaja: Arendusmaailmas on niimoodi. Kui on oma toode ja oma mingeid asju tehakse, siis ei pruugi olla. On neid ettevõtted, kes ei ei Monitoori ega ürita logida aega Aga enamus ettevõtted Pigem seda teevad. Eriti kui on rätsepa Arendusettevõtted rätsepaks Kutsun. Mina neid, kes teevad lihtsalt raha eest, kellele iganes arendust
Õpetaja: onju, tuleb sisse. Mingi projekt tehakse ära ja võetakse pappi, sest et ega, ee, väga harva, nagu tänapäevas arendusmaailmas ee Võetakse vastu nagu mingi tüki töö. Nagu hindajad.
Õpetaja: Tee mulle selline asi ja lepime kokku Rahas. Seal on nii palju nagu tee ainult niukene Loll viga. Nagu siis tuleb klient, kes nagu mingi igal sammul hakkab nagu midagi äppima, et. Ei, ei, ma mõtlesin teistmoodi ja teeme selle asja. Ka Ja pärast on niimoodi viis kuud. Istud selle projekti otsas ja oled omavahel miinuses, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, ainult väga üksikud ettevõtted, kes Võibolla on väga sarnaseid projekte juba teinud. Võivad seda pakkuda. Ma tean näiteks Kunagi siin. Vahepeal oli mingi maan ja nende online kasiinodega ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: Meid tellitakse nagu lademetest. Nagu viisakamad ja eetilisemad ettevõtted ei tegele niukse jamaga.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga näiteks Niuke asi kui sa oled juba Mingi Kümme niiöelda online kasiinot teinud siis. Sa võid ee lüüa käed noh. Ma, Tean et nii on, tehtud nagu
Õpetaja: kakskümmend tuhat ja teeme ära. Siis nad teavad, mis sinna sisse läheb, onju?
Õpetaja: Enamus hinnastamine on ikka tundidega. Ja kui sa ee, lööd kellegiga käed, siis sa löödki käed. Vaata, et. Noh, et ee, seeniorarendaja eest küsime viiskümmend eurot tunnis ja
Õpetaja: juuniori eest. Küsime nii palju. No need on need numbrid, mida teile loomulikult ei öelda. Vaata, mida teie eest küsitakse. Vaata, aga te ka enda. Nagu enamvähem. Mingit suurusjärku niikuinii teate, on ju
Õpetaja: ja siis Ongi see, et selles samas selles samas taask is on võimalik aega logida.
Õpetaja: Paned sinna kirja? Kulutasin kaheksa tundi või ühe päeva või viisteist minutit. Ja, noh, mingi täpsus on nagu ta oleks kokku lepitud.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja ma ütlen ka, et mõned kohad nagu tavaliselt on nagu enamus Kohad on nagu niimoodi, et nädala lõpus pead oma tunnid ära vlogima. Vaata, ee, mõnes kohas ka niimoodi Igapäevas. Palun markeeri ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, need, Kus on oma toode? Seal ka ikkagi. Tihtipeale tahetakse seda teha sellepärast, et suured ülemused ikkagi tahavad näha. Nagu, et me võtame mingi suure. Asja näiteks ette. Palju see asi meile maksma läks? Nemad ikka teevad niimoodi, et ee, kuskil miitingutel räägivad nemad rahanumbritest, mitte tundidest,
Õpetaja: Ma olen Sada tuhat selle peale. Nagu kulutanud. Nagu midagi taolist. Vaatas, et nad teavad. Nagu Noh, nad panevad. Kas Outsourc I hinnamise ka ütleme viiskümmend Eurot tundi ongi Kõik On ju, et tahetakse ikka teada. No, Niukene väiksem metšali. Kas on see otsene ülemise asi Tahab võibolla lihtsalt seda näha, et nagu. Noh, kuhu see aeg, läheb?
Õpetaja: Et ega te. See on pigem tavaline, et on mitu arendusülesannet korraga käinud, on nagu käsil Teed mingit ühte asja. Mingi aeg, siis võibolla tuleb mingi takistus või asi. Teed Natuke teist asja, et see on nagu, väga, okei, ee, Mõni asi nagu järsku ülemus ütleb. Kuule, see on tähtsam. Tee see ära, Vaata, onju? Mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Ee ja. Ja ma ütlen, hästi tavaline Ongi see ka, et vahepeal pead lihtsalt midagi ootama vaata, et ei saa nagu kuidagi edasi liikuda. Vaata siis sa nagu toimetad selle nende ülesannetega
Õpetaja: suurtemate asjadega. Pigem nagu räägitakse, et. Kuule, meil on mingi uus asi tulemas. Oled sa nii loll, et Paned sinna oma nime taha, Vaata või noh, tahad või ei? Taha? On ju mingisugust väiksemat ilulilu, mis on nagu mingi mõttetu. Seal ei ole nagu mingit erilist vestlustki, Võibolla, et mingid ülemused kuskil vaatavad seal mingi
Õpetaja: mingi miiting, kus nad lihtsalt otsustavad, et, noh, see. See töö sellises järjekorras sa lihtsalt paned mingi nimed taha ja. Läheb ja hästi. Palju on ka niukest kultuuri, kus arendajad ise võtavad. Raske on olemas
Õpetaja: Back Log on siis kõik Taaskid, mis on juba süsteemi lisatud. Aga nime pole taha pandud.
Õpetaja: Kes Seda, nagu tegema Hakkab, onju? Mina panen siin praegu sign to me Siis lõpptulemus on sama. Et see on nagu tuleb minu dashboard. Ile. See on minu ülesanne. Tehniliselt võttes siis, kui ma hakkasin sellega tegelema, Siis ma oleks ka enda pidanud panema in progress.
Õpetaja: Noh, nende näidetega, mis siin on? Need staatused on seda saab kõik ise muuta. Ja Et mis sammud? Kuidas liikuma? Edasi, tagasi ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: siis, kui seda niiöelda teed. Noh, võibolla läheb sellega mingi päev või kaks aega Või rohkem. Mis iganes
Õpetaja: siis mingi hetk on ta näiteks siin Review, mis on siia juurde tekkinud. Vanasti polnudki seda siin vaikimisi Code Review Või testimine võib ka enda sama mõelda. Ja siis ühel hetkel ta on Done.
Õpetaja: Noh, vaatavad loomulikult Boardi Boardi peal on siin mingid mitmed Taasklid, mis on? Nimed on taga Näete. Nimed. Taasklid on ikka mingid pildid Ka Ettevõttes ikka paned mingi pildi et vaatad, kes mille käes on, Millega ta tegeleb? Vaata ja mis on nagu läinud. Siin saab ka neid asju tõsta. Vähemalt vanasti sain, Aga
Õpetaja: see staatus. Taustal muutub Chira muidugi.
Õpetaja: Laul või tähtaeg lähemale.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: vot see. Vot siin on see ka, et. Noh, kui teil nagu hakkab üldse mingit valikuvõimalust olema, et te kuhugi suundite. Vaata onju, et siis, kui te olete ee, rätsepas, siis on deadline Id. Pigem pigem aktuaalsemad. Kliendil on midagi lubatud.
Õpetaja: Millal midagi saab Valmis On ju? Kui te olete ettevõtetes, kus mingi omi asju arendatakse. Ee, siis seal ei pruugi olla nagu selliseid tähtaegu, Mis Nagu on nagu see, et peab Jumala eest valmis saama. Aga võiks valmis saada. Ja kui läheb üle, siis nagu keegi nagu pikali ei kuku ja,
Õpetaja: ee, vallandama ei hakka, Onju Aa, ja siis võibolla ka vahel, mis tulevad väljapoolt. Noh, näiteks Lhv S. Meil enamus arendused Olid ju võtsime midagi iseendale ette. Ja, noh, ka enne, nagu mõtlesime, et kaua meil läheb? Sellega Või nii? Aga otseselt kuupäev ei olnud Keegi hinga kuklasse Ei hinganud. Välja arvatud siis, kui oli välissüsteemi muudatused.
Õpetaja: Meie pangandussüsteemid suhtlevad teiste süsteemidega. Seal süsteemis tuleb muudatus. Need arendused olid Niimoodi, et sellel kuupäeval sellel minutil toimub üleminek,
Õpetaja: Siis ka oleme ka valmis.
Õpetaja: Mina neid arendusi tegin ka Iga kord. Kui ma seda tegin, Siis ma ütlesin, nagu kurat küll. Nagu ma saan aru, mis teised seda vastu võetud. Vaata,
Õpetaja: see ikka Korralik pressure, loomulikult. Kogu tiim ja üldse nagu hakkavad Viimasel hetkel.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, et. Oot, kõik teavad nagu kuradi aasta aega ette seda kuupäeva ja iga kord on mingi tormamine ja Mingi räme. Mingi Kütmine
Õpetaja: ee. Nagu, järsku oleks tulnud et, by the way nädala Aja pärast peame kõik asjad. Ära tegema onju
Õpetaja: kui, kui, Jõutakse sinnamaani
Õpetaja: Ei, no pangast nagu nalja ei tehta. Vaata aga, aga. Noh, seal on ka nagu need scruomi Niiöelda miitingud, et seal on Teatud nagu miitingud Ee, mis on nagu ette planeeritud. Ee, kui uus mingi projekt või asi on midagi vaja teha,
Õpetaja: retro on see, kui Kõik on tehtud, siis tiim tuleb kokku ja arutab kolm asja, mis läheks hästi. Kolm asja, mis läheks halvasti. Vaata, mida oleks saanud paremini teha Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt, ee. Mina kaks korda tegin ühe ühe ühe sama süsteemi niiöelda tähtajalist arendust. Ee, Ja siis oli mõlemal nagu Sellel retrol oli kokkuvõte, et oleks võinud varem hakata sellega pihta. Vaata, et oleme siis järgmine kord targemad. Järgmine aasta täpselt sama kama, Vaata Onju
Õpetaja: nii, ta on. Noh, kogu aeg on igasuguseid asju teha. On ju, et, ee, et ajalogimist tuleb ette Minule pigem meeldiks ettevõte, kus Ei ole ajalogimist. Ee, kui on, siis on. Noh, mis seal ikka
Õpetaja: alguses oled nagu kuidagi juuniorina, hullult piinlikult täpne ja paned seal mingit enam vähem igat minutid kirja Vaata, lõpus on niimoodi. Seda, et päeva lõpus paned kaheksa tundi kirja ja et vaata, et tegelikult tegid ühte taski ja teist taaski. Paned lihtsalt ühe ühe arvele? Kui sa teed rätsepavärki. Seal on nagu peab täpne olema. Seda klienti pillitakse, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga Jah, üldiselt see on ka siis selline nagu kaine. Nagu piitsavärk Ka et nagu kaua sa istud selle taskiga, et, ee, muuda ära kolm tähte, Nagu, et
Õpetaja: see lõpuks jääb silma
Õpetaja: Nii taaskond tehtud. Ee. Siis mis nüüd see tähendab? Aa on see, et peaks see asi minema Kuidagi Masterisse mäletate? See asi. Me nüüd hakkame mängima Aa Kas teil on Aa alles veel mõni. Aa, mõni haru, mis on lihtsalt teienimeline
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: kurat, mängime seda homme. Ma natukene valmistan selleks nagu ette, et Kuidas, mängida. Point on see. Vaata, teeme homme seda. Point on see, Vaata, et see on arenduse haru, Aga see, Oota, mida meil on nagu see. Vaata päris Production is Master on siis tavaliselt see haru, Mis läheb nii öelda serverisse nagu kliendile
Õpetaja: Ja sinna, nagu peavad kõik asjad kokku kogunema. Siin on jälle kultuur ja tava ka. Aa, paljud ettevõtted Teevad. Siis aa seda strateegiat, et on olemas Niuke Haru nagu Master ja on develop.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on kõik arendusharud veb neliteist ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aa, meil näiteks Lhv. S oli ka. Oli tegelikult Aa alguses. Develop oli ka. See mõte. Oli nagu see. Vaata, et me Iga nädal reliisime kõik, mis on kõlbulik ja sobib ja ei ole katki ja töötab ja oleks vajalik ja oleks hea kliendile, mis võiks Nagu jõuda nagu ühel või teisel viisil Või meile endale On ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis korra nädalas näiteks. Ee, see oli ta siis kolmapäev Inside Info, kolmapäeva kesköö. Ee, see oli siis statistiliselt kõige tõenäolisem aeg kus on kõige vähem kliente?
Õpetaja: Konkreetselt taga tavaliselt mingi keskööd oli. Ee, noh, oli mõeldud. Siis arendajatele ka, onju? Vaata, et keegi, kes seda asja nagu läbi viib, nagu enamvähem, viitsid veel üleval olla. Vaata, et tehti Niuksed uuendused Ja siis ongi niimoodi, et, ee, nädal aega Põhimõtteliselt kõik, mis oli test ribute Code Reviewed, kõik olid nagu läbi käinud. Vaata, On ju sobis, et võib minna nagu Live I Alguses koguti Developharule.
Õpetaja: Nad ei läinud kohe Vaata sinna mastaraalule
Õpetaja: ja siis sealt kogu see Kompott tõsteti nagu ühe liigutusega lükati serverisse. Kui kõik läks, hästi siis oli. Ja noh, kõik töötas. Vaata, on ju aga mingi aeg tegelikult Saadi aru, et tegelikult see on ikkagi tobe. Ega see, et kui mingi asi harusse läheb, ei tähenda, et ta kohe läheb serverisse,
Õpetaja: Ee, hiljem hakati optimeerima. Nagu seda tööosa ka. Vaata, et üleüldse. Vaata need projektid, kus oli võimalik automatiseerida ära,
Õpetaja: et, ee, niiöelda ee, selle asja Serverisse tõstmisel ei peaks midagi käsitsi tegema kopima mingeid faile ja toksima mingeid käske. Asju Kõik automatiseeriti ära ja siis
Õpetaja: Aa, oli nagu, et Mis me sinna develop isse ikka tõstame. Tõstame siis kohe otse Masterisse. Develop kadus ära. Siis Ongi nagu meie. Nagu see värk Masterist, võtad alati uue haru Teed töö ära. Kui kõik on hästi ja sobib, et läheb serverisse, siis merg ime Masterisse ja see läheb Live keegi Aitab nuppu. Server Käivitub.
Õpetaja: Läheb uus asi nagu päriselt ka. Vaata, onju? Nagu siis tööle tööle. Ee, meie teeme niukest asja, aga nüüd on See, et me saaksime harjutada ja kõike asju. Me kõik ei saa mängida selle ühe ainsa Masteri vastu selle sama arendusega.
Õpetaja: Siis me teeme Niimoodi, et igal ühel hakkab olema, Ee, oma varasemad haruldahemad Remote St. Võibolla te võiksite ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja, noh, võibolla see, mis on Nagu enda nimeline võiks ka tegelikult lokalist olla, Et meil kõigil võiks nüüd olla lihtsalt üks omanimeline haru. Minul on õpetaja Jaroslavil on Jaroslav. Triinul on triin ja nii edasi ei ole neid vee ühte ega V kahte. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja me mängime nagu seda. Et see on nagu selles mõttes teie Master,
Õpetaja: et ma kujutate ette, et te võtate Masterist uue haru ja mörsite sinna. Me ei saa kõik mängida Masteri vastu. Lihtsalt Jaroslav on Jaroslavi Master. Lihtsalt õpetaja või Raini. Niiöelda, Master on õpetaja. Iga kord, kui me teeme arenduse haru, siis me Võtame enda selle Masteri peal
Õpetaja: ühe uue haru Teeme tööd ja siis lõpuks viime selle töö sinna tagasi. Meil on tähtis harjutada seda tegevust, Sest see on see, mis teid ootab
Õpetaja: ees. Vahet pole, mis keelt või raamistikku te lähete tegema. See on kõik sama,
Õpetaja: et võimalikult palju Harjutame seda. Ja kui teil tuleb ju tiimitöö, siis teil tiimiprojektis ongi? Tegelikult harunimega, Master. Ja igakord, kui võtadki, mingi, noh, ütleme, hakkab tiimis tööd tegema. Ta võtab oma haru
Õpetaja: ja hakkab seal toimetama. Ja mingi hetk siis lükkab Masterisse Vahepeal, võibolla keegi teine on sinna midagi, onju, Et selles mõttes te saate siis ka nagu päris kuju praegult. Lihtsalt me ei saa kõik Masteri vastu mängida. Masterit,
Õpetaja: Master Last. Olgu, Master, Sinna keegi ei tee. Mina teen samamoodi. Õpetaja, Minu master. Mängin, et see on Master.
Õpetaja: Saite mõttes aru? Its, Again. Ee, me peame mängima, Me peame mängima pere või Mis see vanasti oli? Kodu.
Õpetaja: Me mängime praegu arendust.
Õpetaja: Siis. Ee. Siis võib teha niimoodi. Noh, te saate teha Niimoodi, et ee võite võtta lihtsalt, ee, õpetaja pealt ühe haaru
Õpetaja: New Branch ja teete ühe haaruga. See on ainult lihtsalt teie nimi, suurte Tähtedega.
Õpetaja: Masteriga muidugi meelde. Kui kihti paned, Seal läheb konflikti. Sest, ee, kui sul on ee süsteem, mis on master, siis kiht tahab ikkagi minna.
Õpetaja: Seda tuleb muuta.
Õpetaja: Tal olid konkreetselt selle projektiga.
Õpetaja: Master on nagu nii nagu persona. Jah, et jah, võib olla küll, nii,
Õpetaja: kas te Need, kes kaasa tegid, komitasite oma töö ära. Vaata ja see läks sinna sellesse arendusharusse, on? Nii
Õpetaja: on jälle nii vähe. Ma arvan, et Ee,
Õpetaja: ee Teeme niimoodi, et ee,
Õpetaja: teeme. Okei, teeme praegu niimoodi. Ma ütlen, kell on jälle nagu, nii palju, et viimased minutid, onju, et Vaatame seda homme asja Mängime seda homme seda asja nagu uuesti läbi.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen, et see läheb praegult Ee, liiga segaseks. Teeme niimoodi Et Praegult. Ee, Teeme siis niimoodi, et selle arendustaskiga mina nagu selle Ära ja tee, nagu veel ei mängi kaasa. Me me tahame teatud asju läbi simuleerida ja mängida me praegu seda ei tee. Ee, sest et see jääks täiesti pooliklikuks.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina igal juhul mängin siis niimoodi, nagu päriselus seda tegelikult teha ei saa. Ee, sellepärast Masterisse ei saa kunagi otse merge
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et see tähendaks seda, et mina omavoliliselt ee mergin mingisuguse koodi. Meie Production koodi, kus mitte keegi seda tegelikult otseselt ei ole üle vaadanud ja ei ole pannud pöialt, et selline liigutus enamus Ettevõtetes on Master on Protection I all.
Õpetaja: Masterisse ei ole võimalik, Merch. Ida Masteris on ainult asju võimalik saada.
Õpetaja: See Tähendab seda, et ma ei saa arvutist teha liigutuse ära, et. Hei, see Feb. Neli töö. Ma soovin, et ma panen selle Masterisse ja teengi selle liigutuse ära Ja siis push in pilve.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi. Enamus kohtades ei saa. Sellepärast, et.
Õpetaja: Noh, pangas. Nagu. Võibolla võiks teha niimoodi mingi väike kood, et iga Viies sent läheb. Vaata, onju, et oleks väga tšilli. Billy.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal on Niukene. Asi on juba siis sisse kirjutatud. Et see vajab tegelikult pöialt.
Õpetaja: Nagu ma mõtlen. Nagu seda, et ei saa midagi juurde tulla. Ennem kui see on nagu tehniliselt seal, selles kitarri keskkonnas ära lahendatud
Õpetaja: Ennem kui keegi tuleb ja paneb nagu mingi niukse asja. Pruud ei ole võimalik sinna nagu panna. See garanteerib juba ära, et keegi, nagu Kellel ei ole nagu päris õigust. Ee, ja noh, siis saab mingid üldised reeglid panna. Vaata, et sa ei saa olla see või mis iganes või selle pöidla panija iseendale.
Õpetaja: See annaks võimaluse, et keegi ei pane tähele. Ma ruttu. Teen mingisuguse väikse koodilõigu sinna juurde Ja
Õpetaja: kas Siis kas siis tingimata, et nagu rahi hakkab kuskile tiksuma? Aga võibolla on seal mingi väike back toor mul tulevikus. Ee, mis iganes onju
Õpetaja: Et Masterisse, nagu väga niimoodi otse asju ei saa, käib ee, ühe läbiva triki. Aga homme räägin sellest. Ee, täpsemalt võiks tulla veits isukam taas ka kui see. Ja siis me mängime nagu seda, mängime Code Review D ja mingit niukest asja ka,
Õpetaja: mida mina praegu lihtsalt teen, Enda pealt on see, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: mul on töö ära kommititud. Siia, Feb Nelja läks tagasi mingisuguse kommitiga nimega,
Õpetaja: mis ta nüüd läks? Ma Vaatan kohe
Õpetaja: Fm. Neli komplit, on nii? Ma mängin nüüd oma selle õpetaja vastu.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis praegult ei ole siin Seda Feb nelja kompliiti Seda tööd ei ole siin.
Õpetaja: See töö on endiselt nagu selle aru peal.
Õpetaja: Kui ma soovin nüüd, et üks töö läheb teise sisse ja Ma saan seda siin oma arvutis teha. Siis käib alati suunas.
Õpetaja: Me ei saa asju Push Ida, Mina ei saa istuda oksal Feb, neli Ja lükata tehtud tööd. Ee, õpetaja Harusse. Mina pean istuma õpetaja harul ja tõmbama Feb nelja töö sisse. Sa lihtsalt on vaja teada. Vaata, et kui sa tahad Merch Ida, vaata siis kummal oksal sa pead istuma.
Õpetaja: Sellel oksal. Pead istuma. Kuhu töö peab minema,
Õpetaja: Sest et kui Nüüd hakkame seda tegema ja tuleb mingi konflikt. Siis saabki lahendada ja öelda, et kuidas üks ja teine asi peab jääma lõpus ja sinna see jääb. Me ei saa kuskile, kus ma ise peal ei ole. Jällegi, Vaata, sa pead töötama kuskil harus.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan uut tööd teha, Siis ole selle haru peal. Kui sa tahad seda uut tööd teha, Kui sa tahad mingeid muudatusi sisse, sinna haarusse, kuhu sul on vaja. Siis Sa pead selle peale istuma. Ikka lihtne rusikareegel.
Õpetaja: Läheb selle õpetaja peale. Ta on checkout.
Õpetaja: Teil on lihtsalt vaatamise koht. Homme mängime seda asja nagu nullist uuesti. Ma annan talle väikse ülesande kätte. Nagu selles mõttes, et te võiksite kõik oma ee sellised harud ära kustutada, Võibolla ja alustada. Kustutage homme kõik ebavajalikud harud remoodist ära.
Õpetaja: Lähed lihtsalt remoodi peale oma nime? Peale? Panete tele,
Õpetaja: et meil homme, Kui me alustame. Me saaksime siis puhtalt alustada ja mängida seda stsenaariumit nagu. Nagu viisakalt läbi.
Õpetaja: Jah, point on lihtsalt see, et teil on kõigil praegu Neljad, onju?
Õpetaja: Küsimus on, kuhu te oma tehtud tööd tahate tõmmata?
Õpetaja: Selles on õpetajasse. Ei saa sellepärast õpetajasse mööžin. Mina,
Õpetaja: et mängime homme seda Selles mõttes uuesti. Ee, ja ma praegult ei tee seda ka nii nagu me homme teeme. Praegu Ma teen nagu Cheat Code. Ma lähen Õpetaja peale.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan, et praegu lihtsalt õpetajasse jääks. Kõik, nagu mis on vaja. Ee, ma teen checkout I niimoodi oma tiimitöödest te saate teha. Te ei pea tegema purriku hästi. Kas teil on Niukene Kiire, agiilne arendus? Vaata, kus ei ole aega nagu teha kõike nii nagu päriselus,
Õpetaja: sest tal pole niisugust aega.
Õpetaja: Ee, teen. Olen õpetaja peal Ja mina nüüd olen õpetaja peal ja ma lähen oma selle feb nelja peale ja ütlen, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: see on nüüd koht, kus te alati peate hakkama tõmbama pidurit. Vaata, kui muidu on klikk, klikk, klikk, siis siin. Kui te hakkate Merch operatsiooni tegema, siis te korra jääte seisma niimoodi hoolega ja siis te loete nüüd selle Mersi juures oleva info ja mõtlema. Mõtlete, et kas te võite kogemata proovida asju teha? Valetpidi
Õpetaja: Siin ütleb seda.
Õpetaja: Merch Feb, Neli intu õpetaja.
Õpetaja: See Tähendab seda, et
Õpetaja: Tehtud tööd. Mis on Feb? Neljast lähevad sinna. Õpetaja Päriselus. Loeksin praegult Merch Feb. Neli into master.
Õpetaja: Kui Sa loed niisuguse asja välja ja Sa mõtled, Peaasi, et ma tegin tehtud tööd ja ma tahan, et sa lähed Masterisse. On see õige, Siis vajuta nuppu, kui sa praegu Lugesid niisuguse asja välja, nagu tiimitöödesse saaks olla. Merch Master into vm neli.
Õpetaja: Sa tegid just arenduse tööd ja sa tahad masterisse saad aru, et see on. See on valetpidi. Ma istun valel oksal.
Õpetaja: Ma pean minema selle haru peale. Kuhu töö peab minema, et ma pean Masteri Peale minema
Õpetaja: ei juhtu mitte midagi. Alguses sa ei lähe. Seal ei ole. Oota, Näed, Mers Ei, ole nagu see, et võta kõik üle Mm, ei, ei,
Õpetaja: ee. Kik on muudatuste kontrollimine.
Õpetaja: Kui Mina praegu näiteks mitte midagi ei juhtu, teeme vastupidi. Ma lähen korra. Praegu. Ma lähen Rahulikult oma feb nelja peale. Checkout.
Õpetaja: Eelselt keegi. Mas minu õpetaja all ei ole midagi. Kui mina praegu ütlen, nagu, et, ee, õpetaja
Õpetaja: Merch, Õpetaja Merch Master Into neli. Siis ta peaks ütlema, et sa oled ja up to date Aga ta ei tee niiöelda, ta ei ta ei kirjuta üle
Õpetaja: minu tehtud tööd.
Õpetaja: See ei ole ohtlik. See on isegi tegevus, mida on vaja teha Master, into arendusharu Räägime. Siis, kui Konfliktideni jõuame, et see ei tee midagi.
Õpetaja: Already up to Date.
Õpetaja: Õpetajas ei ole praegult mingisugust tehtud tööd, mida minu Feb neljas ei ole olemas. Mina võtsin haru ju õpetaja pealt. Kõik, mis oli õpetajas, on ka minul.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma teen nüüd teistpidi,
Õpetaja: siis siin ma ju tegin. No mõtlen, et vaatame seda kittöriistaga Siit alt, On ju?
Õpetaja: Õpetajas? Ei ole seda, Feb. Neli komplit Õpetaja. Feb on eesmärk, on, et See jõuaks siia.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis niipidi ei juhtu mitte midagi. Seda ei pea absoluutselt kartma.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on nüüd isegi tervitatav tegevus siis, kui te oma tiimi projektidega toimetate. See on nagu väga hea asi, mida teha.
Õpetaja: Aga ma räägin siis, kui sinna jõuame. Mina olen nüüd siis Nagu oma Masteri peale ja ütlen, et Hei, teeb neli
Õpetaja: into master. Jah, nüüd ta ütles et ta tegi selle ära.
Õpetaja: Merched õpetaja, õpetaja, Ee, ahah. Näete, mis ta siin vaikimisi aknas all ka kohe pakub. Mis ta mulle pakub?
Õpetaja: Kustuta ära. Ee, ma tahan homme natuke sellest pikemalt rääkida, Aga väikene siis diiser kohe selle kohta ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina nagu algajana. Juuniorina pidevalt Nagu kui ma tegin mingeid arendusi, Ee, siis, Ee, ma ei kustutanud neid harusi, ära millega ma varem olin toimetanud. Mingis imelikus. Hirmus, et äkki läheb vaja,
Õpetaja: Kui sa need asjad siis see Ei, tähenda. Vaata. Joonised näitavad, et üks haru läheb teise sisse. See on nüüd see. Kahjuks See illustratsioon jätab nüüd niukse imeliku mulje, Vaata, et asjad kaovad nagu ära. Vaata, et teda enam ei ole. Ei, ole, see Haru on endiselt tegelt lahti.
Õpetaja: See haru on endiselt olemas. Sa saad endiselt minna selle haru peale ja teha tööd, ida, pushida ja kõike. Mida See, haru on seal seni kaua, kuni see on ära kustutatud. Isegi kui sa lõpuks selle ära kustutatud, siis see ajalugu, et see haru oli olemas ja alles joonistan
Õpetaja: nüüd mina, vanasti Jätsin kogu aeg neid alles, et. Aga äkki läheb vaja?
Õpetaja: Aga sa, mis iganes töö sa tegid ära, see on juba sul Masteris olemas
Õpetaja: Kui sa kustutad selle ära ja mingil imelikul põhjusel on ikka vaja veel mingi muudatus teha ja on tingimata vaja, et on see sama Niiöelda taski numbriga.
Õpetaja: Võta siis master ist uus varu ja pane selle nimeks see sama taaskinumber, mis on nagu varem võib olla ära kustutatud,
Õpetaja: et ei ole nagu mitte ühtegi põhjust, miks ta peaks alles olema. Aga on palju põhjuseid, miks ta ei tohiks seal olla enam alles
Õpetaja: Kui Teil hakkavad tulema. Numbrid Nagu üheksa, kuus, üheksa, üheksa, üheksa kuus ja ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Teil tulevad lõpuks seal niuke numberpliness varem või hiljem. Kui teil on mingid vanad You gonna
Õpetaja: nüüd. Okei? Sa tahad oma lokali all hoida neid kõiki asju alles? Fine, ole siis selline, Hoia siis neid. Ma ei tea, mille jaoks,
Õpetaja: aga mis puudutab Remote Seal on küll. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Kui Remote ist mingi asi mörgitakse Masterisse, siis Ta pakub samamoodi sulle delete.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult tuleb see, Kui me õigesti seda asja teeme. Kohe pean oskama. Ära ka
Õpetaja: vaata. Seal on niimoodi, et et mõelge niimoodi, kui meil oleks. Ee, tõesti. Noh, põhimõtteliselt. Lhv s olidki juba seal. Ühe rakenduse taaskid olid juba üheksasada miljoniga,
Õpetaja: kui meil on seal. Ee selles remoodi all ligi. Üheksa saad aru,
Õpetaja: Siis on rämedalt scroll Imist. Nagu üldse, et mingi. Kas sa näed kõiki neid Numbreid
Õpetaja: neid pole vaja. Kõik need mineviku tööd on juba alati mastaris olemas. Versiooni ajalugu, mis? Mida toimus. Kõik on taustal. Tegelikult olemas.
Õpetaja: Pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Ainukene asi, mis sa võid tekitada, on see, et sa tekitad kellegile teisele mingeid probleeme, kuna keegi teine pärast võtab kogemata Hoopis sinu Mingi vana haru, mis on ammu läbi.
Õpetaja: Seda kutsutakse Kitty hügieeniks.
Õpetaja: Sa lähevad remoodi alt. Kui töö on tehtud ja Masterisse ära niiöelda mösitud, Siis tehniliselt see haru tuleb ära kustutada. See töö on juba olemas.
Õpetaja: Me hoiame võimalikult puhtana seda, kuidas hakkab see tegelikult üsna, kiirelt silma, et on mingi vana pask. Seal igas ettevõttes on keegi, kes ikka hoiab silma selle peal ka. Ja kui sa jätad sinna mingi vana Haru, mis on ammu ära tehtud, siis avalikku häbiposti. Sind häbiposte. Sind lüüakse üle kanali. Sealt hõigatakse, et
Õpetaja: kes selle arenduse tegija on? No nimi on niikuinii taskist näha. Vaata, kes on. On näha, et see on kompliit. Ammu Juba
Õpetaja: siis öeldakse, et Kuule, kas seda arendust sa veel teed. See on nagu, tegelikult selge, et. Noh, see on see mõte. On põhimõtteliselt nagu suunata su käitumist, et Kustuta see ära, vaata on ju, kuidas see silma paistab?
Õpetaja: No, kui täna tehakse uus tiket ja selle number on tuhat viissada ja va neid arusaam remoodist igalt poolt näha. Sa näed, et seal on mingisugune taask, mis on mingi üheksasada. Sa mõtled, et okei? Viissada taaski on vahepeal siin reisitud, et tehtud. Vaata, on ju. Ilmselt see on. Noh, see on nii väike number teiste numbrite kõrval. Ilmselt See on vana.
Õpetaja: Vahel võib olla lihtsaid põhjused. Aga siis tavaliselt on taask lahti ka, et et ootamegi mingisuguse välise sü süsteemi kinnitust või? Või keegi peab mingi oma pöidla andma Või mingi värk on. Vaata, mis hoiab. Mõni asi võib väga kaua väga kaua ka istuda, aga siis tavaliselt on see esiteks lahti, et taaskond lahti ja taaski juures on kommentaar,
Õpetaja: et ootame nüüd endiselt siin mingisugust otsustada, kus iganes,
Õpetaja: et Ee, hoidke seda hügieeni, Ee, see ma Ütlen, et see on mingi algaja värk. Ma ise tunnen ka seda. Oli niimoodi alguses, et mingisugune imelik tunne, et Ee, põhimõtteliselt ma pean neid vanu asju, nagu hoidma.
Õpetaja: Kuulge, tõmbame joone alla.
Õpetaja: Ee, me saame homme rääkida neid asju natukene uuesti. Mis me ka just nüüd õhtupoole tegime. Tavaliselt. Ma teen natuke niimoodi, et võtame veits kokku.
Õpetaja: Ee, et me, saame neid rääkida. Kõik tehniliselt.